( >> I BET YOU ALL ARE
THRILLED ABOUT THE WEATHER.
WE ARE.
>> IT'S A WONDERFUL DAY TO BE IN
OLD CAMPUS.
WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT THUNDER
AND LIGHTNING.
IT MAY BE HOT.
ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT YOU
PEOPLE HAVE HAD A VERY LONG
WEEKEND.
IT'S A LOT OF TALKING, A LOT OF
WALKING AROUND, A LOT OF
EXHAUSTION.
AND WE HOPE YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
SIT BACK AND ENJOY THIS
COMMENTARY FOR A LITTLE WHILE
AND WE'LL TELL YOU AS MUCH AS WE
CAN ABOUT WHERE YOUR CHILDREN
ARE AND WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> AND WE HOPE YOU CAN ENJOY THE
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT YOU ALL
SHARE WITH ALL OF YOUR GRADUATES
TODAY.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE DAY FOR
EVERYONE.
>> SO, I MEAN, THIS IS
COMMENCEMENT.
WHAT DOES COMMENCEMENT MEAN?
IT IS A BEGINNING.
IT IS A MOMENT OF TRANSITION FOR
EVERYONE WHO IS PART OF IT.
UNDERGRADUATES ARE GOING ON TO A
NEW LIFE.
GRADUATES STUDENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL STUDENTS ARE GOING
ON TO PROFESSIONAL CAREERS.
BUT I ALSO THINK OF IT AS A DAY
OF CELEBRATION FOR THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSITY.
IT'S THE ONLY DAY IN WHICH
EVERYONE IN THE UNIVERSITY CAN
BE GATHER GATHERED IN ONE
PLACE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND YOU SEE A LOT OF POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE.
YALE IS FULL OF A LOT OF IT.
AND I REALLY THINK OF IT AS A
CELEBRATION OF EDUCATION AS A
KIND OF MOMENT WHERE WE
CELEBRATE TRANSFORMATION AND
WHEN WE CELEBRATE THE AGE AND
OUR BELIEF THAT EDUCATION IS
TRANSFORMATIVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND PENNY, YOU MENTIONED THAT
THIS IS THE ONE DAY THAT WE ALL
GATHER IN ONE PLACE.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT OLD CAMPUS
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
BE HERE TOGETHER WITH US TODAY
AND WHAT THIS PLACE MEANS?
>> YES.
WE'RE -- SO, WHERE ARE WE?
WE'RE SITTING ON THE OLD
CAMPUS.
IT'S CALLED THE COMMENCEMENT
THEATER.
IT'S ONLY A THEATER BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF CHAIRS HERE AND A
STAGE.
OTHERWISE IT'S NOT A THEATER.
AND IF YOU'RE SITTING HERE, IN
BACK OF YOU IS THE OLD -- THE
BRINGING BUILDING IS THE OLDEST
BUILDING AT YALE.
IT WAS BUILT IN 1701.
IT'S HAD A BIT OF TRANSFORMATION
SINCE THEN.
AND THIS IS THE OLDEST PART OF
YALE AND THAT'S THE OLDEST
BUILDING AT YALE.
IT NOW HOUSES THE PHILOSOPHY
DEPARTMENT.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF IT HAS THE
FACULTY ROOM, THE IMPORTANT
UNDERGRADUATE FACULTY ROOM.
AND SO, WHAT ELSE IS HERE ON THE
OLD CAMPUS, DO YOU KNOW, GARTH?
>> WELL, I'M QUITE NEW TO THE
UNIVERSITY, BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT ALL OF OUR FIRST YEARS LIVE
HERE ON OLD CAMPUS.
>> NOT ALL OF THEM.
>> NOT ALL, OKAY.
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT A GOOD NUMBER OF THEM.
SOME OF THE COLLEGES, FOUR OF
THEM ARE BIG ENOUGH TO HAVE
FIRST YEAR YEARS LIVE RIGHT
INSIDE THEM.
BUT OTHERWISE EVERYBODY IS HERE
ON THE OLD CAMPUS, YES.
>> ANOTHER THING I LOVE ABOUT
THE OLD CAMPUS IS THE TRADITION
THAT IS EMBEDDED IN THE
WALKWAYS.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT?
THE PATHWAYS AND HOW THEY
INTERSECT?
MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT THE
ORIGINAL DESIGN OF THE OLD
CAMPUS QUAD INVOLVED THESE
INTERSECTING PATHWAYS SO THAT
THESE STUDENTS WHO WOULD COME
TOGETHER FROM FAR AND WIDE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PASS THROUGH
THESE GATES AND ACROSS THIS QUAD
WITHOUT BUMPING INTO EACH
OTHER.
AND IT'S THAT SORT OF
INTERSECTION THAT THE UNIVERSITY
HAS ALWAYS BEEN STRIVING FOR AND
INDEED KNOWN FOR MORE AND MORE
EACH YEAR AS THE STUDENT BODY
GETS MORE AND MORE DIVERSE.
>> YOU'LL NOTICE A TREMENDOUS
NUMBER OF CHAIRS HERE.
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE
GETS BIGGER EVERY YEAR.
AND WE CAN -- WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN NUMBERS,
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE HERE, HOW MANY
GRADUATES, WE HAVE ABOUT 1340
UNDERGRADUATES.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT 110 FROM THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
58 FROM THE SCHOOL OF ART.
110 FROM MUSIC.
FORESTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STUDIES HAS ABOUT 150.
PUBLIC HEALTH, 231.
DIVINITY, 145.
THE LAW SCHOOL HAS 225.
DRAMA, 75.
AND HERE IS ONE OF THE YOUNGEST
SCHOOLS AT YALE, MANAGEMENT, THE
SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT, HAS 522
STUDENTS AND IT'S GETTING BIGGER
EVERY YEAR.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'RE
GOING PUT THEM LATER.
BUT WE'LL SEE.
ARCHITECTURE HAS 75.
AND THE GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS
AND SCIENCES WHICH INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING THEIR
MASTERS AND THEIR DOCTORATES IS
480.
AND NURSING HAS 139.
>> FOR A TOTAL OF 5,139
GRADUATE, PROFESSIONAL AND POST
DOCTORAL STUDENTS.
>> YEAH.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WE'RE NOT
THE SIZE OF OHIO STATE OR THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
BUT WE'RE A NICE MEDIUM-SIZED
SCHOOL.
BUT WHEN YOU PUT EVERYBODY
TOGETHER, THAT'S QUITE A FEW
UNDERGRADUATES AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS AND QUITE A NUMBER OF
FAMILIES TO PUT ON THE OLD
CAMPUS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YEAH.
YOU MIGHT ASK, WHAT IS THIS
CEREMONY YOU'RE ATTENDING?
AND WHY ARE YOU HERE?
AND WHY ARE YOU GOING TO ANOTHER
CEREMONY AFTERWARDS?
>> RIGHT.
WELL -- I THINK THE THING THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR ABOUT FIRST
IS, WHERE ARE OUR GRADUATES
RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH.
OKAY.
WHERE ARE OUR GRADUATES?
WHERE ARE YOUR GRADUATES?
WELL, THEY ARE ALL LINING UP.
A GOOD PART OF THIS PROGRAM IS
PROCESSION.
YOU WILL BE HERE, THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE ON OLD CAMPUS, WHEN THE
PROCESSION COMES DOWN THIS
MIDDLE AISLE HERE IN ALL ITS
GLORY.
BUT RIGHT NOW THESE GRADUATES
ARE LINING UP ALL OVER CAMPUS.
THE UNDERGRADUATES ARE LINING UP
IN THEIR RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES.
THE 14 RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES.
THEY PROBABLY WENT TO BED VERY
LATE LAST NIGHT.
>> IT'S BEEN A BIG WEEK.
>> PEOPLE ARE TELLING THEM TO
GET DRESSED AND HURRY UP AND GET
OUT.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THEIR
GOWNS.
THERE'S ALSO SOMEBODY WHO DIDN'T
ORDER HIS OR HER GOWN AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AROUND FOR A
GOWN FOR THEM.
THEY'RE LINING UP.
THE GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE LINING
UP EITHER IN THEIR SCHOOLS AND
PROCESSING TO THE CROSS CAMPUS,
OR WAITING TO COME IN THESE
OTHER GATES OF THE UNIVERSITY.
ON THE CROSS CAMPUS YOU'LL SEE
THE FACULTY OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES, THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE, THE YALE COLLEGE
DEAN'S OFFICE, ALL THE
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES.
LINING UP AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO SEE, I THINK,
SOME OF THAT ON THE SCREEN.
AND IN THE VARIOUS SCHOOLS,
PEOPLE ARE ALSO LINING UP AND
IT'S A MOMENT OF JOYOUS
CELEBRATION.
THEY'RE SEEING THEIR FRIENDS.
THEY'RE SEEING THEIR TEACHERS.
AND THEY'RE HAVING REALLY A
WONDERFUL MORNING, I THINK.
YOU'RE SITTING HERE WAITING.
THOSE OF YOU IN THE COMMENCEMENT
THEATER.
BUT THEY'RE ENJOYING THEMSELVES
WITH THEIR FRIENDS AND
TEACHERS.
>> IT REALLY IS A BEAUTIFUL
CONVENING.
THESE STUDENTS SPEND ALL YEAR
TOILING AWAY IN THEIR SEPARATE
COLLEGES AND THEIR SEPARATE
SCHOOLS.
CAN -- AND ON THIS MORNING AS
THEY ALL PASS INTO CROSS CAMPUS
AND SEE THE BANNERS ANNOUNCING
WHERE ALL OF THE SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES SHOULD LINE UP, THEY
COME TOGETHER AND GATHER AS THIS
GROUP OF SCHOLARS THAT REALLY
HAS NO PARALLEL.
>> YES.
AND NOW, THEN YOU MIGHT WANT TO
KNOW WHERE IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNIVERSITY?
WHERE IS THE DEAN OF THE
FACULTY?
WHERE IS THE PROVOST?
WHERE ARE ALL THE HONORANTS?
WHERE ARE THEY?
THEY ARE LINING UP IN STERLING
MEMORIAL LIBRARY.
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY ENJOYING A
CUP OF COFFEE.
AND A LITTLE BREAKFAST.
AND THEY'RE TALKING WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
AND THEY'RE ROBING.
THEY'RE PUTTING ON THEIR ROBES.
AND THEY'RE GETTING DIRECTIONS
ABOUT HOW THE MORNING WILL GO.
>> SURE.
>> AND EVENTUALLY, THEY WILL BE
THE LEADERS OF THE PROCESSION,
THE LEADERS OF THE PEOPLE COMING
INTO THIS COMMENCEMENT THEATER.
BUT THAT WILL BE A WHILE FROM
NOW.
>> PENNY, YOU MENTIONED A FEW
MINUTES AGO WHAT A BUSY WEEKEND
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN HAVING
ALREADY.
AND WHAT'S ALREADY HAPPENED THIS
WEEKEND IS BACCALAUREATE AND
CLASS DAY.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THOSE
INCREDIBLE CEREMONIES?
>> YES, YES.
SO, CLASS DAY WAS YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON.
PEOPLE OFTEN ASK, DOES -- WHO IS
YALE'S COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER?
>> RIGHT.
>> AND, AS A MATTER OF FACT, NO
ONE SPEAKS AT A YALE
COMMENCEMENT EXCEPT THE
PRESIDENT AND THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY CONFERRING DEGREES OR
ASKING THE PRESIDENT TO CONFER
DEGREES.
THE ONLY EXCEPTION IS WHEN A
SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS PRESENT.
AND THEN HE OR MAYBE SOMEDAY SHE
GETS TO MAKE A SHORT
COMMENTARY.
OTHER THAN THAT, NO ONE -- NO
ONE -- THERE'S NO COMMENCEMENT
ADDRESS.
HOWEVER, THERE IS A CLASS DAY
A CLASS DAY IS PARTICULARLY FOR
ADDRESS.
THE UNDERGRADUATES.
A CLASS DAY IS PARTICULARLY FOR
BUT MANY PEOPLE SHOW UP FOR THE
THE UNDERGRADUATES.
ADDRESS EVEN IF THEY DO NOT HAVE
BUT MANY PEOPLE SHOW UP FOR THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE CELEBRATING
ADDRESS EVEN IF THEY DO NOT HAVE
UNDERGRADUATE CLASS DAY.
CHILDREN WHO ARE CELEBRATING
>> IT'S VERY INSPIRING.
UNDERGRADUATE CLASS DAY.
>> YES.
>> IT'S VERY INSPIRING.
AND YESTERDAY WE HAD CHIMAMANDA
>> YES.
ADICHIE.
AND YESTERDAY WE HAD CHIMAMANDA
SHE WAS ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL.
ADICHIE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR
SHE WAS ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL.
PROGRAMS, YOU'LL SEE THAT TODAY
AND IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR
SHE IS RECEIVING AN HONORARY
PROGRAMS, YOU'LL SEE THAT TODAY
DEGREE.
SHE IS RECEIVING AN HONORARY
SO, THAT WAS INSPIRATIONAL.
DEGREE.
AND CLASS DAY IS REALLY A
SO, THAT WAS INSPIRATIONAL.
LEFTOVER FROM THE DAYS WHEN
AND CLASS DAY IS REALLY A
THERE WERE ONLY ABOUT A HUNDRED
LEFTOVER FROM THE DAYS WHEN
PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
THERE WERE ONLY ABOUT A HUNDRED
>> WOW.
PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
>> AND THE DAY BELONGED ENTIRELY
>> WOW.
TO THE PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
>> AND THE DAY BELONGED ENTIRELY
AND THEY SAT AROUND IN A BIG
TO THE PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
CIRCLE AND THEY RIBBED EACH
AND THEY SAT AROUND IN A BIG
OTHER.
CIRCLE AND THEY RIBBED EACH
AND THEY TOLD STORIES.
OTHER.
AND THEY SANG SONGS.
AND THEY TOLD STORIES.
AND THAT'S PART OF WHAT CLASS
AND THEY SANG SONGS.
DAY IS.
AND THAT'S PART OF WHAT CLASS
AND THE OTHER PART OF CLASS DAY
DAY IS.
ARE ACADEMIC AWARDS.
AND THE OTHER PART OF CLASS DAY
HIGH STAND AWARDS.
ARE ACADEMIC AWARDS.
AWARDS THAT ARE GIVEN TO THE
HIGH STAND AWARDS.
VERY, VERY MOST ACCOMPLISHED
AWARDS THAT ARE GIVEN TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
VERY, VERY MOST ACCOMPLISHED
ALTHOUGH, OF COURSE, THEY
PEOPLE IN THE CLASS.
REPRESENT OTHERS WHO ARE
ALTHOUGH, OF COURSE, THEY
EXTREMELY ACCOMPLISHED.
REPRESENT OTHERS WHO ARE
AND THAT'S A RESIDUE FROM THE
EXTREMELY ACCOMPLISHED.
VERY, VERY OLD DAYS IN WHICH
AND THAT'S A RESIDUE FROM THE
COMMENCEMENT WAS ACTUALLY A
VERY, VERY OLD DAYS IN WHICH
MOMENT WHEN THE GRADUATES SPOKE
COMMENCEMENT WAS ACTUALLY A
AND THEY HAD TO UNDERGO A GREAT
MOMENT WHEN THE GRADUATES SPOKE
DEAL OF EXAMINES FROM THEIR
AND THEY HAD TO UNDERGO A GREAT
TUTORS AND FROM THE PRESIDENT.
DEAL OF EXAMINES FROM THEIR
AND THE RESIDUAL OF THAT IS SOME
TUTORS AND FROM THE PRESIDENT.
OF THE SPEECHES THAT GO ON.
AND THE RESIDUAL OF THAT IS SOME
BUT ALSO THE AWARDS CEREMONIES.
OF THE SPEECHES THAT GO ON.
SO, CLASS DAY PUTS TOGETHER TWO
BUT ALSO THE AWARDS CEREMONIES.
VERY ANCIENT PARTS OF
SO, CLASS DAY PUTS TOGETHER TWO
COMMENCEMENT.
VERY ANCIENT PARTS OF
THE PART -- THE ACADEMIC PART
COMMENCEMENT.
AND THE PART IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE
THE PART -- THE ACADEMIC PART
CELEBRATING EACH OTHER AND JUST
AND THE PART IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE
HAVING A REALLY GOOD TIME.
CELEBRATING EACH OTHER AND JUST
>> AND THOSE AWARDS THAT ARE
HAVING A REALLY GOOD TIME.
CONFERRED AT CLASS DAY, THEY
>> AND THOSE AWARDS THAT ARE
PLAY INTO TODAY'S CEREMONY AS
CONFERRED AT CLASS DAY, THEY
WELL, IS THAT RIGHT?
PLAY INTO TODAY'S CEREMONY AS
>> THEY DO.
WELL, IS THAT RIGHT?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO WON WHAT
>> THEY DO.
ARE CALLED THE HIGH STAND AWARDS
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO WON WHAT
CARRY SOME OF THE BANNERS.
ARE CALLED THE HIGH STAND AWARDS
>> OKAY.
CARRY SOME OF THE BANNERS.
>> BUT IN TALKING ABOUT CLASS
>> OKAY.
DAY, WE'RE TALKING ONLY ABOUT
>> BUT IN TALKING ABOUT CLASS
UNDERGRADUATES.
DAY, WE'RE TALKING ONLY ABOUT
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
UNDERGRADUATES.
>> BECAUSE ALL OVER THE CAMPUS
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YESTERDAY THERE WERE OTHER
>> BECAUSE ALL OVER THE CAMPUS
THINGS GOING ON.
YESTERDAY THERE WERE OTHER
CELEBRATIONS, GATHERINGS.
THINGS GOING ON.
SOMETIMES SCHOOLS HAVE SPECIAL
CELEBRATIONS, GATHERINGS.
EVENTS GOING ON.
SOMETIMES SCHOOLS HAVE SPECIAL
>> OKAY.
EVENTS GOING ON.
>> AND, OF COURSE, LAST NIGHT
>> OKAY.
MANY, MANY, MANY DINNERS AND
>> AND, OF COURSE, LAST NIGHT
OTHER KINDS OF CELEBRATORY
MANY, MANY, MANY DINNERS AND
EVENTS.
OTHER KINDS OF CELEBRATORY
SO, YES.
EVENTS.
NOW, THE BACCALAUREATE.
SO, YES.
THE BACCALAUREATE IS THE LEVER
NOW, THE BACCALAUREATE.
OF WHERE, OF COURSE, YALE WAS A
THE BACCALAUREATE IS THE LEVER
CONGREGATIONAL SCHOOL.
OF WHERE, OF COURSE, YALE WAS A
BACCALAUREATE IS A LEAVE-OVER
CONGREGATIONAL SCHOOL.
FROM WHAT WERE REALLY RELIGIOUS
BACCALAUREATE IS A LEAVE-OVER
CEREMONIES.
FROM WHAT WERE REALLY RELIGIOUS
AND CONGREGATIONAL CEREMONIES IN
CEREMONIES.
WHICH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
AND CONGREGATIONAL CEREMONIES IN
UNIVERSITY WHO IN THE EARLY DAYS
WHICH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
WAS ABSOLUTELY A PREACHER, WOULD
UNIVERSITY WHO IN THE EARLY DAYS
BE ADDRESSING THE GRADUATES.
WAS ABSOLUTELY A PREACHER, WOULD
THE UNDERGRADUATES.
BE ADDRESSING THE GRADUATES.
AND TODAY, THIS CEREMONY IS NOT
THE UNDERGRADUATES.
A RELIGIOUS CEREMONY.
AND TODAY, THIS CEREMONY IS NOT
BUT THE PRESIDENT ALWAYS GIVES
A RELIGIOUS CEREMONY.
AN ADDRESS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT ALWAYS GIVES
THE DEAN OF YALE COLLEGE GIVES
AN ADDRESS.
SOME REMARKS IN QUOTATIONS.
THE DEAN OF YALE COLLEGE GIVES
AND IT TAKES THE UNDERGRADUATES
SOME REMARKS IN QUOTATIONS.
BACK TO THEIR FIRST MOMENTS AT
AND IT TAKES THE UNDERGRADUATES
YALE WHEN THEY ALSO SAT IN
BACK TO THEIR FIRST MOMENTS AT
WOOLSEY HALL AND LISTENED TO THE
YALE WHEN THEY ALSO SAT IN
PRESIDENT AND THE DEAN.
WOOLSEY HALL AND LISTENED TO THE
AND NOW THEY'RE COMING FULL
PRESIDENT AND THE DEAN.
CIRCLE AND LISTENING TO THEM
AND NOW THEY'RE COMING FULL
AGAIN.
CIRCLE AND LISTENING TO THEM
THERE'S A LOT OF TALKING AROUND
AGAIN.
COMMENCEMENT.
THERE'S A LOT OF TALKING AROUND
SO, THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
COMMENCEMENT.
A COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER, I THINK,
SO, THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
IS PERFECTLY FINE.
A COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER, I THINK,
>> RIGHT.
IS PERFECTLY FINE.
>> SO, FROM HERE, AFTER THIS
>> RIGHT.
CEREMONY, PEOPLE WILL GO TO
>> SO, FROM HERE, AFTER THIS
ANOTHER CEREMONY.
CEREMONY, PEOPLE WILL GO TO
AND MAYBE WE SHOULD TALK A
ANOTHER CEREMONY.
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
AND MAYBE WE SHOULD TALK A
BETWEEN THEM?
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
>> SURE.
BETWEEN THEM?
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> SURE.
>> YEP.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> WELL, I DID HAVE A QUESTION
>> YEP.
FOR YOU THOUGH.
>> WELL, I DID HAVE A QUESTION
>> YEAH.
FOR YOU THOUGH.
>> YOU NOTED THAT THIS DAY'S
>> YEAH.
CEREMONY IS NOT CHARACTERIZED BY
>> YOU NOTED THAT THIS DAY'S
A LOT OF SPEAKING.
CEREMONY IS NOT CHARACTERIZED BY
ALTHOUGH, WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT,
A LOT OF SPEAKING.
I THINK THAT THE HERALDRY AND
ALTHOUGH, WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT,
THE PAGEANTRY OF IT HAS A
I THINK THAT THE HERALDRY AND
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EMBEDDED
THE PAGEANTRY OF IT HAS A
MESSAGING AND HISTORY.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EMBEDDED
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS, CAN YOU
MESSAGING AND HISTORY.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS, CAN YOU
ROBES AND THE COLLARS AND THINGS
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
THAT WE WILL SEE WHEN WE START
ROBES AND THE COLLARS AND THINGS
TO SEE THE GRADUATES AND THE
THAT WE WILL SEE WHEN WE START
FACULTY PROCESS?
TO SEE THE GRADUATES AND THE
>> YES.
FACULTY PROCESS?
YES.
>> YES.
SO, ONE OF THE REASONS I THINK
YES.
YALE HAS SO MUCH HERALDRY SO
SO, ONE OF THE REASONS I THINK
MANY BANNERS, SO MANY PINS, SO
YALE HAS SO MUCH HERALDRY SO
MANY SHIELDS, SO MUCH OF THAT IS
MANY BANNERS, SO MANY PINS, SO
NOT ONLY THAT WE WANT -- WISH TO
MANY SHIELDS, SO MUCH OF THAT IS
SHOW OURSELVES IN FULL POMP AND
NOT ONLY THAT WE WANT -- WISH TO
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE CELEBRATION
SHOW OURSELVES IN FULL POMP AND
OF THE DAY, BUT WE PROBABLY HAVE
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE CELEBRATION
MORE THAN ANY OTHER SCHOOL.
OF THE DAY, BUT WE PROBABLY HAVE
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAD
MORE THAN ANY OTHER SCHOOL.
WHAT'S CALLED A GENTLEMAN.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAD
HIS NAME WAS TUBBY SIZER, TEDDY
WHAT'S CALLED A GENTLEMAN.
SIZER.
HIS NAME WAS TUBBY SIZER, TEDDY
BUT HE WAS CALLED TUBBY.
SIZER.
HE WAS ONE OF THE MONUMENT MEN
BUT HE WAS CALLED TUBBY.
IN WORLD WAR II WHO AFTER THE
HE WAS ONE OF THE MONUMENT MEN
WAR BEGAN TO LOOK AT WHAT HAD
IN WORLD WAR II WHO AFTER THE
HAPPENED TO ALL OF THE GREAT ART
WAR BEGAN TO LOOK AT WHAT HAD
FROM THE MUSEUMS AND WHERE IT
HAPPENED TO ALL OF THE GREAT ART
WAS AND TO IDENTIFY IT AND TO
FROM THE MUSEUMS AND WHERE IT
GET IT PACK TO -- BACK TO ITS
WAS AND TO IDENTIFY IT AND TO
ORIGINAL OWNERS.
GET IT PACK TO -- BACK TO ITS
AND HE WAS ALSO AN EXPERT ON
ORIGINAL OWNERS.
HERALDRY.
AND HE WAS ALSO AN EXPERT ON
AND SO, HE INVENTED ALL OF THESE
HERALDRY.
SHIELDS AND BANNERS.
AND SO, HE INVENTED ALL OF THESE
AND MANY OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
SHIELDS AND BANNERS.
SEE ON THE MACES.
AND MANY OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
AND THE PAGEANTRY OF IT IS A
SEE ON THE MACES.
GREAT PART OF WHAT IS NOW YALE'S
AND THE PAGEANTRY OF IT IS A
COMMENCEMENT.
GREAT PART OF WHAT IS NOW YALE'S
I DON'T THINK YOU SEE QUITE THIS
COMMENCEMENT.
MUCH IN ANY OTHER UNIVERSITY.
I DON'T THINK YOU SEE QUITE THIS
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF IT.
MUCH IN ANY OTHER UNIVERSITY.
>> YEAH, I'VE CERTAINLY NOT SEEN
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF IT.
THIS LEVEL.
>> YEAH, I'VE CERTAINLY NOT SEEN
AND IS THIS THE TITLE PER
THIS LEVEL.
SUEVANTE?
AND IS THIS THE TITLE PER
>> IT IS.
SUEVANTE?
AND IF WE HAVE A PERSON WHO
>> IT IS.
DEALS WITH THE HERALDRY AT YALE
AND IF WE HAVE A PERSON WHO
AND ALL THE BANNERS AND WHAT
DEALS WITH THE HERALDRY AT YALE
HAPPENED WHEN WE HAD TWO NEW
AND ALL THE BANNERS AND WHAT
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES?
HAPPENED WHEN WE HAD TWO NEW
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE HAVE A NEW
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES?
SCHOOL?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE HAVE A NEW
WHO DEVELOPS ALL THE BANNERS AND
SCHOOL?
ALL THE HERALDRY FOR THAT?
WHO DEVELOPS ALL THE BANNERS AND
WELL, MOST OF THAT IS DONE NOW
ALL THE HERALDRY FOR THAT?
BY THE UNIVERSITY PRINTER WHO IS
WELL, MOST OF THAT IS DONE NOW
JOHN GAMBLE.
BY THE UNIVERSITY PRINTER WHO IS
HE DESIGNED, I BELIEVE, THE
JOHN GAMBLE.
FLAGS FOR THE NEW COLLEGES.
HE DESIGNED, I BELIEVE, THE
THE BANNERS FOR THE NEW
FLAGS FOR THE NEW COLLEGES.
COLLEGES.
THE BANNERS FOR THE NEW
AND SO, IT CONTINUES.
COLLEGES.
WE CONTINUE WITH THAT
AND SO, IT CONTINUES.
TRADITION.
WE CONTINUE WITH THAT
WHICH YOU'LL SEE IN FULL
TRADITION.
FLOURISH TODAY.
WHICH YOU'LL SEE IN FULL
ON THE SCREEN -- YES, WE JUST
FLOURISH TODAY.
SAW A NUMBER OF THE BANNERS
ON THE SCREEN -- YES, WE JUST
WHICH YOU'LL SEE LATER COMING
SAW A NUMBER OF THE BANNERS
DOWN THE WALKWAY.
WHICH YOU'LL SEE LATER COMING
>> IT'S FASCINATING TO ME HOW
DOWN THE WALKWAY.
THIS -- THESE BANNERS AND THESE
>> IT'S FASCINATING TO ME HOW
CRESTS.
THIS -- THESE BANNERS AND THESE
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
CRESTS.
AROUND FROM TIME IMMEMORIAL.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
BUT AS THE UNIVERSITY CONTINUES
AROUND FROM TIME IMMEMORIAL.
TO EVOLVE, SO DOES THE
BUT AS THE UNIVERSITY CONTINUES
HERALDRY.
TO EVOLVE, SO DOES THE
>> YES.
HERALDRY.
>> THE SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT IS
>> YES.
NEW, AND MURRAY IS KNEW -- NEW
>> THE SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT IS
AS WELL.
NEW, AND MURRAY IS KNEW -- NEW
>> NOW, THE ROBES.
AS WELL.
HERE WE SEE SOME ROBES ON THE
>> NOW, THE ROBES.
SCREEN.
HERE WE SEE SOME ROBES ON THE
WHAT ABOUT THE ROBES AND WHO
SCREEN.
WEARS WHAT ROBE?
WHAT ABOUT THE ROBES AND WHO
WELL, THE FIRST THING IS THAT
WEARS WHAT ROBE?
YOU DON'T WEAR THE ROBE OF THE
WELL, THE FIRST THING IS THAT
SCHOOL WHERE YOU ARE TEACHING.
YOU DON'T WEAR THE ROBE OF THE
YOU ALWAYS WEAR THE ROBE OF THE
SCHOOL WHERE YOU ARE TEACHING.
INSTITUTION WHERE YOU RECEIVED
YOU ALWAYS WEAR THE ROBE OF THE
YOUR HIGHEST DEGREE.
INSTITUTION WHERE YOU RECEIVED
SO, I AM SITTING HERE WEARING A
YOUR HIGHEST DEGREE.
CRIMSON ROBE.
SO, I AM SITTING HERE WEARING A
THAT'S NOT A YALE ROBE.
CRIMSON ROBE.
IT'S A HARVARD ROBE.
THAT'S NOT A YALE ROBE.
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE BEEN AT YALE
IT'S A HARVARD ROBE.
FOR 45 YEARS, I'M WEARING A ROBE
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE BEEN AT YALE
WHERE I RECEIVED MY PH.D.
FOR 45 YEARS, I'M WEARING A ROBE
>> AND I'M PROUDLY WEARING MY
WHERE I RECEIVED MY PH.D.
BACHELOR OF ARTS ROBE FROM
>> AND I'M PROUDLY WEARING MY
CONNECTICUT COLLEGE RIGHT UP THE
BACHELOR OF ARTS ROBE FROM
COAST.
CONNECTICUT COLLEGE RIGHT UP THE
>> AND YOU ARE WEARING A HOOD
COAST.
WHICH HAS A WHITE VELVET ON IT.
>> AND YOU ARE WEARING A HOOD
>> YES, THANK YOU.
WHICH HAS A WHITE VELVET ON IT.
>> AND DO YOU KNOW WHY?
>> YES, THANK YOU.
>> WELL, THAT'S PART BACHELOR OF
>> AND DO YOU KNOW WHY?
ARTS, CORRECT?
>> WELL, THAT'S PART BACHELOR OF
>> IT'S BACHELOR OF ARTS, BUT
ARTS, CORRECT?
IT'S ALSO -- IT ALSO -- YOU'LL
>> IT'S BACHELOR OF ARTS, BUT
SEE HUMANITIES AND LIBERAL ARTS
IT'S ALSO -- IT ALSO -- YOU'LL
AWARDS TODAY.
SEE HUMANITIES AND LIBERAL ARTS
AND THEY'RE -- THEY WILL BE
AWARDS TODAY.
WHITE.
AND THEY'RE -- THEY WILL BE
>> OKAY.
WHITE.
>> THEY WILL BE WHITE.
>> OKAY.
SO, YOU CAN TELL SCHOOLS WHEN
>> THEY WILL BE WHITE.
YOU SEE THEM -- OH, THERE'S --
SO, YOU CAN TELL SCHOOLS WHEN
THERE'S THE DOG.
YOU SEE THEM -- OH, THERE'S --
THERE IS HANDSOME DAN, LADIES
THERE'S THE DOG.
AND GENTLEMEN.
THERE IS HANDSOME DAN, LADIES
>> HANDSOME DAN.
AND GENTLEMEN.
>> HANDSOME DAN IS THE YALE
>> HANDSOME DAN.
MASCOT.
>> HANDSOME DAN IS THE YALE
>> THE FIRST MASCOT.
MASCOT.
>> WELL, HE'S NOT THE FIRST.
>> THE FIRST MASCOT.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> WELL, HE'S NOT THE FIRST.
BUT AS A TRADITION, I BELIEVE
>> THAT'S TRUE.
HE'S THE FIRST --
BUT AS A TRADITION, I BELIEVE
>> THE FIRST MASCOT IN ANY
HE'S THE FIRST --
SCHOOL.
>> THE FIRST MASCOT IN ANY
YES, YES.
SCHOOL.
SO THEY SAY.
YES, YES.
WHAT NUMBER BULLDOG IS HERE?
SO THEY SAY.
>> 18.
WHAT NUMBER BULLDOG IS HERE?
>> YES.
>> 18.
>> IN A LONG LINE OF HANDSOME
>> YES.
DANES.
>> IN A LONG LINE OF HANDSOME
>> HIS NAME IS WALTER AND HE'S
DANES.
EXTREMELY POPULAR.
>> HIS NAME IS WALTER AND HE'S
HE WILL BE LEADING THE
EXTREMELY POPULAR.
PROCESSION.
HE WILL BE LEADING THE
WE ARE BEGINNING TO SEE PEOPLE
PROCESSION.
PROCESS.
WE ARE BEGINNING TO SEE PEOPLE
YOU SEE ON THE GOWNS THEY'RE
PROCESS.
WEARING THESE STOLES WHICH ARE
YOU SEE ON THE GOWNS THEY'RE
CALLED TIPPETS.
WEARING THESE STOLES WHICH ARE
AND THEY HAVE BECOME VERY, VERY
CALLED TIPPETS.
POPULAR LATELY.
AND THEY HAVE BECOME VERY, VERY
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT REALLY
POPULAR LATELY.
FORMALLY ALLOWED AND YET YALE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT REALLY
HAS NEVER DONOR ANYTHING ABOUT
FORMALLY ALLOWED AND YET YALE
THEM.
HAS NEVER DONOR ANYTHING ABOUT
THE MULTI-COLORED STOLES ARE
THEM.
PROBABLY FROM THE
THE MULTI-COLORED STOLES ARE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CULTURAL CENTER
PROBABLY FROM THE
GRADUATION.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CULTURAL CENTER
AND THE OTHER STOLES REPRESENT
GRADUATION.
THE COLLEGE.
AND THE OTHER STOLES REPRESENT
SO, HERE WE SEE COMING IN THE
THE COLLEGE.
YELLOW, WE SEE, I BELIEVE THAT'S
SO, HERE WE SEE COMING IN THE
PIERSON IS COMING.
YELLOW, WE SEE, I BELIEVE THAT'S
AND HERE WE ARE THIS THEY'RE YOU
PIERSON IS COMING.
WILL GOING TO BE PROCESSING.
AND HERE WE ARE THIS THEY'RE YOU
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THIS.
WILL GOING TO BE PROCESSING.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THIS.
PROCESSING TO LINE UP AROUND THE
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
GREEN.
PROCESSING TO LINE UP AROUND THE
AROUND THE GREEN.
GREEN.
NOW, GARTH --
AROUND THE GREEN.
>> YES.
NOW, GARTH --
>> WHY DON'T YOU SAYING IN ABOUT
>> YES.
WHY THEY'RE GOING TO LINE UP
>> WHY DON'T YOU SAYING IN ABOUT
AROUND THE GREEN?
WHY THEY'RE GOING TO LINE UP
>> SO, IF I HAVE MY HISTORY
AROUND THE GREEN?
CORRECT, THE PROCESSION AROUND
>> SO, IF I HAVE MY HISTORY
THE GREEN COMMEMORATES THE VERY
CORRECT, THE PROCESSION AROUND
FIRST YALE COMMENCEMENT WHICH
THE GREEN COMMEMORATES THE VERY
WAS -- WHICH TOOK PLACE IN THE
FIRST YALE COMMENCEMENT WHICH
CHURCH ON THE GREEN.
WAS -- WHICH TOOK PLACE IN THE
SO, TO REMEMBER THAT, THE
CHURCH ON THE GREEN.
UNDERGRADUATES CIRCLE THE GREEN
SO, TO REMEMBER THAT, THE
AND THEN THE -- THE CORPORATION
UNDERGRADUATES CIRCLE THE GREEN
AND THE FACULTY AND THE --
AND THEN THE -- THE CORPORATION
PROCESS THROUGH ALL OF THE
AND THE FACULTY AND THE --
UNDERGRADUATES.
PROCESS THROUGH ALL OF THE
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
UNDERGRADUATES.
IT ALSO SYMBOLIZES YALE'S
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
RELATIONSHIP TO NEW HAVEN AND
IT ALSO SYMBOLIZES YALE'S
THE FACT THAT THE FIRST
RELATIONSHIP TO NEW HAVEN AND
GRADUATION WAS ACTUALLY IN THE
THE FACT THAT THE FIRST
CENTER CHURCH.
GRADUATION WAS ACTUALLY IN THE
>> CENTER CHURCH, THANK YOU.
CENTER CHURCH.
>> YES.
>> CENTER CHURCH, THANK YOU.
WHICH IS STILL THERE ON THE
>> YES.
GREEN.
WHICH IS STILL THERE ON THE
AND BY THE WAY, WHICH IS THE
GREEN.
FOURTH SUCH CHURCH TO BE BUILT
AND BY THE WAY, WHICH IS THE
IN THAT PLACE ON THE GREEN.
FOURTH SUCH CHURCH TO BE BUILT
AND SO, THEY -- AND THEY
IN THAT PLACE ON THE GREEN.
ACTUALLY BUILT IT OVER A
AND SO, THEY -- AND THEY
GRAVEYARD.
ACTUALLY BUILT IT OVER A
>> OH, WOW.
GRAVEYARD.
>> SO, YOU CAN VISIT -- IN THE
>> OH, WOW.
CHURCH YOU CAN VISIT THE CRYPTS
>> SO, YOU CAN VISIT -- IN THE
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE CHURCH.
CHURCH YOU CAN VISIT THE CRYPTS
>> INCREDIBLE.
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE CHURCH.
>> BUT CENTER CHURCH WAS WHERE
>> INCREDIBLE.
COMMENCEMENT WAS FIRST HELD AT
>> BUT CENTER CHURCH WAS WHERE
YALE.
COMMENCEMENT WAS FIRST HELD AT
AND NOW, AND FOLLOWING THAT,
YALE.
IT'S MOVED AROUND A NUMBER OF
AND NOW, AND FOLLOWING THAT,
TIMES.
IT'S MOVED AROUND A NUMBER OF
IT MOVED FROM THERE TO BATTELL
TIMES.
CHAPEL.
IT MOVED FROM THERE TO BATTELL
AND WHEN THERE WERE TOO MANY FOR
CHAPEL.
BATTELL, MOVED TO WOOLSEY HALL.
AND WHEN THERE WERE TOO MANY FOR
AFTER THE WAR WE MOVED IT TO THE
BATTELL, MOVED TO WOOLSEY HALL.
OLD CAMPUS.
AFTER THE WAR WE MOVED IT TO THE
AND NOW YOU SEE THAT IS
OLD CAMPUS.
DAVENPORT COMING DOWN.
AND NOW YOU SEE THAT IS
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE --
DAVENPORT COMING DOWN.
>> WE HAVE BERKELEY.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE --
>> WE HAVE BERKELEY, YES.
>> WE HAVE BERKELEY.
AND YOU SEE AT THE FRONT ARE THE
>> WE HAVE BERKELEY, YES.
HEADS OF COLLEGE.
AND YOU SEE AT THE FRONT ARE THE
AND THE DEANS OF THE COLLEGE.
HEADS OF COLLEGE.
THE BANNERS ARE CARRIED BY
AND THE DEANS OF THE COLLEGE.
MARSHALS WHO REPRESENT THE
THE BANNERS ARE CARRIED BY
COLLEGE.
MARSHALS WHO REPRESENT THE
AND YOU SEE ALL THE FACULTY IN A
COLLEGE.
LINE COMING THROUGH HERE.
AND YOU SEE ALL THE FACULTY IN A
AND AFTER THE FACULTY COME THE
LINE COMING THROUGH HERE.
STUDENTS.
AND AFTER THE FACULTY COME THE
SO, WHO IS THIS?
STUDENTS.
HUH.
SO, WHO IS THIS?
NOT QUITE SURE.
HUH.
>> I THINK WE HAVE DAVENPORT.
NOT QUITE SURE.
>> NO, DAVENPORT IS STILL
>> I THINK WE HAVE DAVENPORT.
COMING.
>> NO, DAVENPORT IS STILL
>> SURE.
COMING.
>> THAT IS BERKELEY.
>> SURE.
THAT'S DAVID SWENSON THERE AND
>> THAT IS BERKELEY.
MEGAN.
THAT'S DAVID SWENSON THERE AND
THAT'S BERKELEY COMING.
MEGAN.
SO, IT WAS BERKELEY ON THE LEFT
THAT'S BERKELEY COMING.
AND DAVENPORT ON THE RIGHT.
SO, IT WAS BERKELEY ON THE LEFT
>> THE LOCATION IS THE NOAH
AND DAVENPORT ON THE RIGHT.
PORTER GATE ON THE EDGE OF CROSS
>> THE LOCATION IS THE NOAH
CAMPUS.
PORTER GATE ON THE EDGE OF CROSS
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF IT
CAMPUS.
ALL.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF IT
>> YES.
ALL.
>> ALL THE SCHOLARS ARE MOVING
>> YES.
AND PROCESSING TOWARDS THE
>> ALL THE SCHOLARS ARE MOVING
GREEN.
AND PROCESSING TOWARDS THE
>> NOW, YOU WHO ARE HERE TO SEE
GREEN.
THE -- YOUR STUDENTS GET
>> NOW, YOU WHO ARE HERE TO SEE
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
THE -- YOUR STUDENTS GET
DEGREES, THEY DO NOT COME
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
THROUGH NOAH PORTER GATE.
DEGREES, THEY DO NOT COME
THEY WILL BE COMING ON EITHER
THROUGH NOAH PORTER GATE.
SIDE OF THE OLD CAMPUS.
THEY WILL BE COMING ON EITHER
THEY'LL BE COMING THROUGH THE
SIDE OF THE OLD CAMPUS.
GATES ON EITHER SIDE.
THEY'LL BE COMING THROUGH THE
SO, FROM THE RIGHT YOU'LL SEE
GATES ON EITHER SIDE.
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND THE
SO, FROM THE RIGHT YOU'LL SEE
SCHOOLS OF THE ARTS.
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND THE
FROM THE LEFT YOU'LL SEE
SCHOOLS OF THE ARTS.
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER
FROM THE LEFT YOU'LL SEE
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER
AND THEY'LL ALL BE CONGREGATING
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
HERE.
AND THEY'LL ALL BE CONGREGATING
IT'S ACTUALLY THE UNDERGRADUATES
HERE.
WHO ARE THE MOST NUMEROUS WHO
IT'S ACTUALLY THE UNDERGRADUATES
ARE LINING UP AROUND THE GREEN.
WHO ARE THE MOST NUMEROUS WHO
AND IT'S A WAY OF THE YOUNGEST
ARE LINING UP AROUND THE GREEN.
STUDENTS AT YALE MAKING A BIG
AND IT'S A WAY OF THE YOUNGEST
CIRCLE THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
STUDENTS AT YALE MAKING A BIG
MEMBERS OF THE CORPORATION AND
CIRCLE THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE -- OF THE FACULTY
MEMBERS OF THE CORPORATION AND
AND DEANS CAN WALK THROUGH.
MEMBERS OF THE -- OF THE FACULTY
IT'S A LOVELY TRADITION.
AND DEANS CAN WALK THROUGH.
WALK THROUGH THE
IT'S A LOVELY TRADITION.
UNDERGRADUATES.
WALK THROUGH THE
AND THEN --
UNDERGRADUATES.
>> AND THERE'S MUSIC.
AND THEN --
THERE'S MUSIC AS WELL.
>> AND THERE'S MUSIC.
THE BAND IS LEADING THEM.
YES.
>> AND THE COLLEGES LINE UP IN
THE BAND IS LEADING THEM.
TWO ROWS SO THAT THE CORPORATION
>> AND THE COLLEGES LINE UP IN
AND THE OFFICERS CAN PROCESS
TWO ROWS SO THAT THE CORPORATION
DOWN BETWEEN THEM LED BY THE
AND THE OFFICERS CAN PROCESS
BAND.
DOWN BETWEEN THEM LED BY THE
IT'S JUST AN INCREDIBLE,
BAND.
INCREDIBLE PROCESSION.
IT'S JUST AN INCREDIBLE,
>> NOW WE SEE ON THE RIGHT I
INCREDIBLE PROCESSION.
WILL SAY THE BEST COLLEGE OF
>> NOW WE SEE ON THE RIGHT I
THEM ALL BECAUSE IT'S MY COLLEGE
WILL SAY THE BEST COLLEGE OF
WHERE I WAS HEAD OF COLLEGE FOR
THEM ALL BECAUSE IT'S MY COLLEGE
EIGHT YEARS.
WHERE I WAS HEAD OF COLLEGE FOR
AND THAT'S JONATHAN EDWARDS
EIGHT YEARS.
COLLEGE ON THE RIGHT WEARING THE
AND THAT'S JONATHAN EDWARDS
GREEN STOLES.
COLLEGE ON THE RIGHT WEARING THE
AND THE FACULTY ARE COMING
GREEN STOLES.
THROUGH.
AND THE FACULTY ARE COMING
AND THEN THE STUDENTS.
THROUGH.
>> AND DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
AND THEN THE STUDENTS.
THAT CREST SINCE WE'RE TALKING
>> AND DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ABOUT JONATHAN EDWARDS AND YOU
THAT CREST SINCE WE'RE TALKING
KNOW IT WELL?
ABOUT JONATHAN EDWARDS AND YOU
>> THE CREST, WHICH IS ON THE
KNOW IT WELL?
STOLES THEY'RE WEARING, IS OF A
>> THE CREST, WHICH IS ON THE
LION RAMPANT.
STOLES THEY'RE WEARING, IS OF A
>> OKAY.
LION RAMPANT.
>> AND THAT IS SIMPLY THE
>> OKAY.
SYMBOL.
>> AND THAT IS SIMPLY THE
THERE IS A LONG HERALDIC REASON
SYMBOL.
FOR THAT.
THERE IS A LONG HERALDIC REASON
IT WAS PART OF THE CREST OF
FOR THAT.
JONATHAN EDWARDS HIMSELF.
IT WAS PART OF THE CREST OF
FAMILY CREST.
JONATHAN EDWARDS HIMSELF.
SO, IN SOME CASES THESE
FAMILY CREST.
INSIGNIAS REPRESENT THE COATS OF
SO, IN SOME CASES THESE
ARMS OF THE PEOPLE WHO STARTED
INSIGNIAS REPRESENT THE COATS OF
THE COLLEGES.
ARMS OF THE PEOPLE WHO STARTED
NOT EVERY COLLEGE IS NAMED FOR A
THE COLLEGES.
PERSON.
NOT EVERY COLLEGE IS NAMED FOR A
>> SURE.
PERSON.
>> SO, OTHERS WERE INVENTED FOR
>> SURE.
OTHER REASONS.
>> SO, OTHERS WERE INVENTED FOR
AND COMING UP BEHIND I SEE
OTHER REASONS.
BRANFORD AND TRUMBULL.
AND COMING UP BEHIND I SEE
THE BULLS ON THE FLAG FOR
BRANFORD AND TRUMBULL.
TRUMBULL.
THE BULLS ON THE FLAG FOR
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
TRUMBULL.
>> AND THE BOOKS ON THE FLAG FOR
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BRANFORD SYMBOLIZING THE BOOKS
>> AND THE BOOKS ON THE FLAG FOR
THAT WERE FIRST GIVEN TO YALE.
BRANFORD SYMBOLIZING THE BOOKS
AND IN BRANFORD WHEN YALE WAS IN
THAT WERE FIRST GIVEN TO YALE.
BRANFORD, CONNECTICUT.
AND IN BRANFORD WHEN YALE WAS IN
>> AH.
BRANFORD, CONNECTICUT.
>> YALE MOVED AROUND QUITE A BIT
>> AH.
BEFORE IT ENDED UP IN NEW
>> YALE MOVED AROUND QUITE A BIT
HAVEN.
BEFORE IT ENDED UP IN NEW
AND THIS IS AN INTERESTING
HAVEN.
THING.
AND THIS IS AN INTERESTING
THERE WAS A BIG FIGHT ABOUT
THING.
WHERE YALE WOULD END UP.
THERE WAS A BIG FIGHT ABOUT
AND THE FIGHT WAS BETWEEN
WHERE YALE WOULD END UP.
HARTFORD --
AND THE FIGHT WAS BETWEEN
>> OH.
HARTFORD --
>> AND NEW HAVEN.
>> OH.
AND IT WAS REALLY INTENSE.
>> AND NEW HAVEN.
>> AND WE KNOW WHO WON.
AND IT WAS REALLY INTENSE.
BUT IN THE FIRST COMMENCEMENT
>> AND WE KNOW WHO WON.
YALE HAD IN 1718 HERE, IT WAS
BUT IN THE FIRST COMMENCEMENT
STILL NOT A COMPLETELY SETTLED
YALE HAD IN 1718 HERE, IT WAS
THING --
STILL NOT A COMPLETELY SETTLED
>> WOW.
THING --
>> THAT YALE WOULD BE HERE.
>> WOW.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE STILL
>> THAT YALE WOULD BE HERE.
FIGHTING TO GET IT TO HARTFORD.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE STILL
>> AND I BELIEVE THE CAPITAL OF
FIGHTING TO GET IT TO HARTFORD.
THE STATE WAS BEING SHARED BACK
>> AND I BELIEVE THE CAPITAL OF
AND FORTH BETWEEN THOSE TWO
THE STATE WAS BEING SHARED BACK
CITIES AS WELL.
AND FORTH BETWEEN THOSE TWO
ONE WHICH WAS HARTFORD,
CITIES AS WELL.
PERCEIVED AS THE CAPITAL OF THE
ONE WHICH WAS HARTFORD,
INTERIOR, AND NEW HAVEN WHICH
PERCEIVED AS THE CAPITAL OF THE
WAS THE CAPITAL HERE ON THE
INTERIOR, AND NEW HAVEN WHICH
COAST.
WAS THE CAPITAL HERE ON THE
>> YES.
COAST.
SO, WE STILL SEE BRANFORD ON THE
>> YES.
RIGHT.
SO, WE STILL SEE BRANFORD ON THE
>> TRUMBULL --
RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
>> TRUMBULL --
AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
>> YEAH.
EVERYBODY IS WEARING THE
AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
STOLES.
EVERYBODY IS WEARING THE
TEN YEARS AGO, NOBODY WAS
STOLES.
WEARING THEM.
TEN YEARS AGO, NOBODY WAS
>> THEY'RE CARRYING THINGS AS
WEARING THEM.
WELL.
>> THEY'RE CARRYING THINGS AS
SOMETIMES FLAGS, SOMETIMES OTHER
WELL.
ITEMS THAT SYMBOLIZE THEIR
SOMETIMES FLAGS, SOMETIMES OTHER
SCHOOLS.
ITEMS THAT SYMBOLIZE THEIR
I SAW THE ACT --
SCHOOLS.
>> YES.
I SAW THE ACT --
AND, OF COURSE, EVERY PROCESSION
>> YES.
IS LED BY MARSHALS WHO DO JUST
AND, OF COURSE, EVERY PROCESSION
WHAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE SUPPOSED
IS LED BY MARSHALS WHO DO JUST
TO DO.
WHAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE SUPPOSED
THEY MARSHAL AND MAKE SURE
TO DO.
EVERYBODY IS IN ORDER.
THEY MARSHAL AND MAKE SURE
OH, HERE COMES THE NEW
EVERYBODY IS IN ORDER.
COLLEGES.
OH, HERE COMES THE NEW
THIS IS PAULI MURRAY COMING
COLLEGES.
DOWN.
THIS IS PAULI MURRAY COMING
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
DOWN.
>> THERE'S A GRAY GOWN AND A
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
CRIMSON GOWN.
>> THERE'S A GRAY GOWN AND A
AND HERE COME THE PAULI MURRAY
CRIMSON GOWN.
STUDENTS AND FRANKLIN STUDENTS.
AND HERE COME THE PAULI MURRAY
THEY'RE WAVING AT YOU.
STUDENTS AND FRANKLIN STUDENTS.
>> NOW, YOU KNOW, I'M LOOKING AT
THEY'RE WAVING AT YOU.
THEIR MORTAL BOARDS -- MORTAR
>> NOW, YOU KNOW, I'M LOOKING AT
BOARDS, AND THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
THEIR MORTAL BOARDS -- MORTAR
TO THIS DAY.
BOARDS, AND THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
BUT IT'S ALSO REMINDING ME OF A
TO THIS DAY.
TRADITION ON CLASS DAY WHICH IS
BUT IT'S ALSO REMINDING ME OF A
THE DECORATING OF THE HATS.
TRADITION ON CLASS DAY WHICH IS
IS THAT RIGHT?
THE DECORATING OF THE HATS.
>> YES.
IS THAT RIGHT?
YOU WILL SEE SOME HATS, USUALLY
>> YES.
IN THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
YOU WILL SEE SOME HATS, USUALLY
>> OKAY.
IN THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
>> USUALLY IN THE PROFESSIONAL
>> OKAY.
SCHOOLS.
>> USUALLY IN THE PROFESSIONAL
NOW, YOU CAN'T BE SURE THEY'LL
SCHOOLS.
DO IT EVERY YEAR.
NOW, YOU CAN'T BE SURE THEY'LL
BUT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
DO IT EVERY YEAR.
FORESTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BUT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
STUDIES BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN
FORESTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
WEARING GREENS ON THE AND
STUDIES BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN
FLOWERS ON THE TOP OF THEIR
WEARING GREENS ON THE AND
CAPS.
FLOWERS ON THE TOP OF THEIR
>> OKAY.
CAPS.
>> THE DIVINITY SCHOOL SOMETIMES
>> OKAY.
HAS HALOS.
>> THE DIVINITY SCHOOL SOMETIMES
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE THE
HAS HALOS.
EXTRAORDINARY INTEREST OF WHAT
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE THE
SOME OF THE SCHOOLS DO WHEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY INTEREST OF WHAT
DEGREES ARE ACTUALLY CONFERRED.
SOME OF THE SCHOOLS DO WHEN THE
AND THE MARSHALS ALL CARRY
DEGREES ARE ACTUALLY CONFERRED.
MACES.
AND THE MARSHALS ALL CARRY
>> OH, THANK YOU.
MACES.
YES.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> YES.
YES.
THEY ALL CARRY MACES.
>> YES.
BUT THEIR MACES ARE OFTEN --
THEY ALL CARRY MACES.
HAVE -- ARE DEDICATED TO WHAT --
BUT THEIR MACES ARE OFTEN --
ARE SYMBOLS OF THEIR COLLEGE.
HAVE -- ARE DEDICATED TO WHAT --
BUT WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOME
ARE SYMBOLS OF THEIR COLLEGE.
VERY, VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE
BUT WE'RE GOING TO SEE SOME
MACES LATER ON WHEN WE SEE THE
VERY, VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE
PRESIDENT'S PARTY AND THE
MACES LATER ON WHEN WE SEE THE
CORPORATION PARTY.
PRESIDENT'S PARTY AND THE
AND THOSE MACES ARE CARRIED BY
CORPORATION PARTY.
MEMBERS OF THE FACULTY.
AND THOSE MACES ARE CARRIED BY
USUALLY RETIRING MEMBERS OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE FACULTY.
FACULTY WHO ARE VERY
USUALLY RETIRING MEMBERS OF THE
DISTINGUISHED AND WHO HAVE BEEN
FACULTY WHO ARE VERY
CHOSE TON CARRY -- CHOSEN TO
DISTINGUISHED AND WHO HAVE BEEN
CARRY THE MACES ON THIS DAY.
CHOSE TON CARRY -- CHOSEN TO
AND I OFTEN LIKE TO TELL PEOPLE
CARRY THE MACES ON THIS DAY.
THAT WHEN YOU GET A BIG AWARD AT
AND I OFTEN LIKE TO TELL PEOPLE
YALE, AT COMMENCEMENT, YOUR
THAT WHEN YOU GET A BIG AWARD AT
AWARD IS REALLY TO CARRY EITHER
YALE, AT COMMENCEMENT, YOUR
A VERY HEAVY BANNER OR A LONG
AWARD IS REALLY TO CARRY EITHER
DISTANCE OR A VERY HEAVY MACE.
A VERY HEAVY BANNER OR A LONG
THOUGH, ONE OF THE MACES WEIGHS
DISTANCE OR A VERY HEAVY MACE.
24 POUNDS.
THOUGH, ONE OF THE MACES WEIGHS
THE UNIVERSITY MACE WEIGHS
24 POUNDS.
AND SOMETIMES THEY HAVE A
YOUNGER PERSON HELPING TO CARRY
THAT MACE.
>> PICKING UP 24 POUNDS IS ONE
THING, BUT CARRYING IT AROUND
FOR AN HOUR IS ANOTHER THING
ENTIRELY.
>> YES.
YES, YES.
I MIGHT SAY A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE HOODS.
AND THEIR COLORS.
SO, WHEN YOU SEE THESE PEOPLE
COMING IN WHO ARE NOT
UNDERGRADUATES, BUT ARE MEMBERS
OF THE GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL, YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO TELL THEM BY THE COLORS ON
THE HOODS THAT THEY'RE WEARING.
SO, WHEN YOU SEE ARCHITECTURE,
WHEN YOU SEE ART AND DRAMA, THAT
WILL BE BROWN.
WHEN YOU SEEDY VINTY, IT WILL BE
SCARLET.
FORESTRY IS RUSSET.
LAW WILL BE PURPLE.
AND WHEN YOU GET A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE TOGETHER, YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO SPOT THEM VERY WELL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND MANAGEMENT WILL BE BLUE.
MEDICINE --
>> THERE'LL BE A LOT OF THOSE.
>> THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
THOSE.
MEDICINE, GREEN.
MUSIC, THE MUSICIANS, WEAR
PINK.
NURSING WEARS APRICOT.
PUBLIC HEALTH WEARS A SALMON
PINK.
AND ENGINEERING WEARS ORANGE.
SO, AS YOU SEE, LARGE GROUPS OF
PEOPLE ENTERING.
THEY'LL BE ENTERING FROM MILLER
GATE AND FROM HIGH STREET.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SPOT LARGE
NUMBERS OF THEM BY THE COLOR OF
THE HOODS THEY'RE WEARING.
NOW, I'M WEARING A HARVARD
HOOD.
HARVARD'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL OF THE HARVARD HOODS ARE
LINED WITH CRIMSON AND THE REST
IS BLACK.
AND YOU CAN TELL WHAT SCHOOL BY
THE CROWS FEET ON THE GOWNS.
SO, THAT IS ACTUALLY A
DIFFERENCE.
IF YOU LOOK AT A HARVARD
COMMENCEMENT, EVERYBODY'S
WEARING THE SAME COLOR.
EVERYBODY LOOKS THE SAME.
BUT WHEN THEY COME IN HERE,
YOU'LL BE ABLE SO SEE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY DIFFERENT.
WHERE IS THE MARCH NOW, I
WONDER?
HOW ARE THEY DOING?
>> WELL, THIS IS SUCH A COMPLEX
DAY.
AND WHO PUTS IT TOGETHER,
PENNY?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
THIS IS REALLY LIKE PUTTING ON A
MAJOR SHOW.
I KNOW GARTH IS A THEATER
PERSON.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU ALWAYS KNOW
THAT WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING ON A
THEATER PRODUCTION, IT TAKES A
LOT OF BACKSTAGE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND THERE IS A UNIVERSITY
EVENTS SINGLE PERSON IN CHARGE
OF THIS ENTIRE DAY AND A NUMBER
OF OTHER UNIVERSITY EVENTS.
AND REALLY PUTTING THIS ALL
TOGETHER IS A TREMENDOUS,
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK.
GATHERING PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER,
TELLING THEM HOW TO PROCESS,
WHAT TO WEAR.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND THEN THINK ABOUT IT,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
NEXT YOU'RE GONNA GO TO YOUR
SCHOOLS AND TO THE RESIDENTIAL
COLLEGES.
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ANOTHER
CEREMONY WHICH HAS A NUMBER OF
MOVING PARTS TO IT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND THINK ABOUT ALL THE HONOR
ANDS YOU'RE GOING IT SEE.
WE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THEM.
AND GETTING THEM TO NEW HAVEN
AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE ALL TAKEN
CARE OF AND FEEDING THEM.
IT'S PUTTING ON A MAJOR, MAJOR
PRODUCTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WONDER WHAT THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF MARSHALS IS TO PUT THIS ALL
TOGETHER.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> THERE ARE MANY TYPES OF
MARSHALS.
MARSHALS FOR THE MARSHAL.
>> AND IT TAKES A SIGNIFICANT
STAFF, A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
INCLUDING FACILITIES.
THEY REALLY DESERVE A HAND FOR
TAKING CARE OF THIS STAGE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> ALL THE ELECTRONIC
BROADCASTING THAT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE.
ALL OF THE TENTS, ALL OF THE
COURTYARD TENTS.
>> ALL OF THE POLICE AND
SECURITY.
THE FOOD SERVICE AND
HOSPITALITY.
>> YES, RAFFI, TERRY AND THEIR
STAFF ARE VERY, VERY BUSY
GETTING THE COMMENCEMENT READY.
>> AND THE LANDSCAPING.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> OH, AND THE GROUNDS.
YEAH.
>> THE GROUNDS.
>> WE'RE REMINDED ON THE
GROUNDS.
THE STAFF HAVE DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB ON GROUNDS.
>> AND NOT JUST HERE ON OLD
CAMPUS.
ALL AROUND THE CAMPUS.
AND AS THE CAMPUS SPILLS INTO
NEW HAVEN, IT'S JUST BEAUTIFUL
THIS TIME OF YEAR.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NO ACCIDENT.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
TO MAKE THIS SO BEAUTIFUL FOR
THIS DAY.
>> YES.
SO, NOW THEY'RE STILL MARCHING
AROUND THE GREEN.
I THINK WE CAN, YOU KNOW, SAY A
FEW WORDS ABOUT THE HONORANDS.
IN THE PROGRAMS YOU'LL SEE THE
WONDERFUL BIOGRAPHIES.
SOMEBODY HAD TO PUT THOSE
TOGETHER.
AND LATER YOU'LL HEAR WONDERFUL
TRIBUTES TO THEM AS THE
PRESIDENT AWARDS THEM THEIR
HONORARY DEGREES.
BUT THERE'S SOME INTERESTING
THINGS TO BE SAID ABOUT THE
HONORARY DEGREES.
IT'S A FABULOUS LIST THIS YEAR.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE.
AND I THINK OF THE MANY THINGS
ABOUT THIS YEAR'S HONORANDS, ONE
THING THAT NEEDS TO BE SAID OFF
THE BAT IS HOW MANY WOMEN
LEADERS ARE REPRESENTED AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS IN THIS YEAR?
DO YOU WANT TO THINK ABOUT
THAT?
>> THE SLATE IS DOMINATED BY
INFLUENTIAL AND POWERFUL WOMEN,
ACTUALLY.
AND THAT IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
2019, 2020 ARE THE
ANNIVERSARIES, FIRST OF THE
50th YEAR OF WOMEN ADMITTED TO
YALE COLLEGE.
AND THAT BIG CELEBRATION WILL
TAKE PLACE NEXT SEPTEMBER.
AND THEN THE 150th, THE
ANNIVERSARY, OF THE FIRST
WOMEN -- WOMAN EVER ADMITTED TO
YALE.
AND THAT'S TO THE SCHOOL OF
ART.
AND SO, THESE CELEBRATIONS WILL
TAKE PLACE DURING THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
AND SO, IT IS -- IT IS REALLY
WONDERFUL BEGIN -- TO BEGIN THIS
YEAR WITH A SLATE THAT INCLUDES
SOME VERY, VERY SIGNIFICANT
WOMEN.
AMONG THEM, CHIMAMANDA ADICHIE
WHO SPOKE YESTERDAY AT CLASS
DAY.
THE WONDERFUL AUTHOR AND TED
TALK -- GIVES A VERY, VERY
FAMOUS TED TALK.
INSPIRATIONAL WRITER.
AND INSPIRATIONAL SPEAKER.
AND MARY BEARD.
THAT'S VERY CLOSE TO MY HEART
BECAUSE SHE'S A VERY GREAT
CLASSIST AS WELL AS A PUBLIC
INTELLECTUAL AND A FEMINIST.
SHEILA HICKS.
THE ARTIST WHOSE SOME OF HER
PAINTINGS ARE AT YALE.
SHE WAS A YALIE, ACTUALLY.
AND WE'RE SO PROUD OF HER AND
HER PAINTINGS ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
CYNTHIA MOSS.
OH, SHE'S GONNA BE A GREAT
FAVORITE.
SHE FOUNDED THE ELEPHANT
PROJECT.
THE AMBERSELE ELEPHANT PROJECT.
SHE'S A GROUND BREAKING
CONSERVATIONIST.
AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
PEPSI COLA, A YALE GRADUATE AND
A MEMBER OF THE CORPORATION FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND SISTER HELEN PREJEAN WHO HAS
ADVOCATED AGAINST THE DEATH
PENALTY AND COUNCILLED MANY,
MANY PRISONERS WHO WERE AWAITING
THE DEATH PENALTY.
THESE ARE WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
AND, OF COURSE, GLORIA STEINEM,
THE FOUNDER OF MS. MAGAZINE,
THAT IS GOING TO BE GREAT FUN.
NOW, WE SHOULDN'T SAY THAT THE
MEN ARE ANY LESS WONDERFUL.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> SO, WE HAVE JAMES BAKER,
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE.
AND WE HAVE LARRY BACOW, THE NEW
PRESIDENT.
WHEN THEY BECOME PRESIDENT, THEY
ALWAYS GET A DEGREE FROM THE
SISTER INSTITUTION.
WE'RE VERY, VERY COMPETITIVE
WITH OUR SISTER INSTITUTION AND
WE ARE ON THE FIELD OF PLAY,
ALWAYS COMPETITIVE.
BUT WE ACTUALLY ARE COMRADES IN
ARMS.
WE'RE COMRADES IN ARMS FOR THE
SAKE OF EDUCATION.
FOR THE GLORY THAT EDUCATION
BRINGS TO NOT ONLY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE, BUT THE RICHNESS OF YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE.
AND SO, IT IS CUSTOMARY TO HONOR
A NEW PRESIDENT OF HARVARD AS
THEY DO AT YALE.
>> AND YOU YOURSELF EMBODY THIS
GREAT TRADITION.
>> I'M WEARING A HARVARD GOWN.
BUT WE'RE DELIGHTED TO HAVE
LARRY BACOW HERE.
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO HAVE HIM
COME.
OH, I FORGOT TO MENTION CARMEN.
SHE'S A DANCER, AND IT'S
FABULOUS TO HAVE HER ON THE LIST
AS WELL.
AND DID WE FORGET ANYONE?
OH, STRIVE MISANEWA, A
BUSINESSMAN FROM AFRICA.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A STUNNING
LIST.
WHY ARE WE GIVING PEOPLE THESE
DEGREES?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> WELL, I DO.
AND I THINK IT SPEAKS TO, YOU
KNOW, WITH EACH DESCRIPTION THAT
YOU SHARED, YOU HEAR THE
STRENGTH OF THESE PEOPLE'S
VALUES COMING THROUGH IN THEIR
WORK.
THEY'RE SO INSPIRING.
AND ALL OF THESE HONORANDS
EXEMPLIFY THE VALUES OF YALE AS
A UNIVERSITY AND INSPIRE OUR
GRADUATES AS THEY GO OUT INTO
THE WORLD.
WHAT ELSE WOULD YOU SAY?
>> LET ME JUST SAY ON THE SCREEN
NOW YOU SEE THE UNIVERSITY
FLAG.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
GREAT PROCESSION.
AND YOU SEE HOW THE YALE FLAG
HERE, BEING CARRIED.
AND YOU SEE THE 24-POUND MACE
BEING CARRIED BY PROFESSOR OF
MATHEMATICS, GRECIA.
>> HIS HOOD WAS DIFFERENT?
THE PRESIDENTS.
>> OH, YES, THE PRESIDENT HAS A
VERY SPECIAL HOOD AND A VERY
SPECIAL GOWN.
AND, OH, HERE ARE THE
HONORANDS.
THERE'S CARMEN DELAVALLADE.
THEY HAVE SOMEONE WITH THEM.
AND HERE'S THE YALE
CORPORATION.
THEY'RE ALL DRESSED IN THE YALE
CORPORATION GOWNS.
OH, AND THERE IS -- YEAH,
CHIMAMANDA ADICHIE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND I SEE JAMES BAKER.
I SEE MEMBERS OF THE CORPORATION
HERE.
ALL MARCHING.
>> AND NOW WE SEE THE DEAN OF
THE COLLEGE, DEAN MARVIN CHUN IN
THE PURPLE AND RED ROBES.
>> OH, HE'S WEARING AN MIT
ROBE.
YES, THIS IS YALE COLLEGE.
HERE COMES YALE COLLEGE.
THERE'S THE DEAN OF ADMISSIONS,
JEREMIAH, MARK SHANKER, ALL OF
THE DEANS OF THE STUDENTS AND
THE DEANS OF YALE COLLEGE ARE
MANNING IN.
>> AND THE BANNER WAS THE BANNER
OF YALE COLLEGE.
>> AND MARY MILLER, THE FORMER
DEAN OF YALE COLLEGE WHO JUST
RETIRED.
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF ARTS
AND SCIENCE, TAMARA, AMY, ONE OF
THE DEPUTY DEANS AND THE WHOLE
PANOPLY OF THE FACULTY OF ARTS
AND SCIENCES IS HERE.
>> BUT NOW WE REALLY SEE THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE ROBES AND THE
HOODS.
>> YES.
SO, THE FACULTY ARE ALL WEARING
THE LOADS FROM THEIR COLLEGE.
YOU SEE A LOT OF BLUE.
THE LIGHT BLUE IS COLUMBIA.
THE ORANGE IS PRINCETON.
THEN PEOPLE ARE WEARING -- SOME
ARE WEARING BLACK GOWNS WITH
THEIR RED HOODS.
I SEE QUITE A BIT OF PRINCETON
THERE.
AND I SEE AN OXFORD GOWN COMING
ALONG.
YOU SEE SOME OF THE
INTERNATIONAL GOWNS.
SO, WHEN YOU SEE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COLORS WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE FACULTY.
>> PENNY, IT'S SUCH A PLEASURE
TO DO THIS WITH YOU AND TO MAKE
COMMENTARY ON THESE IMAGES.
BECAUSE IT'S JUST AN INCREDIBLE
STREAM OF HUMANITY AND YOU
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE.
SO, THANK YOU --
>> WELL, GARTH, IT'S WONDERFUL
TO HAVE YOU HERE TOO.
WE SHOULD SAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THE HEAD OF THE SCHWARZMAN
CENTER, OPENING IN ABOUT A
YEAR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND IT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT,
GREAT SPACE.
LET'S SEE.
HERE COME MORE OF THE UNIVERSITY
FLAGS, THE COLLEGE FLAGS.
THE --
>> GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES.
SO, HERE ARE ALL THE PEOPLE.
THE FACULTY FIRST.
OH, HERE'S THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S THE GREEN HOODS.
>> THIS IS THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE ON THE LEFT.
WALKING IN.
>> NOW WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THE
GRADUATE STUDENTS.
>> YES.
>> WHICH IS WONDERFUL.
>> I'M WELL, THANK YOU.
HI, PROFESSOR MAYHEW, WE'RE ON
THE LIVESTREAM HERE.
YES, WE ARE.
SO, WELL, WE ARE IN A MINUTE.
SO, PROFESSOR MARRY IS ONE --
MAYHEW IS A DISTINGUISHED
POLITICAL SCIENTIST WALKING ON
TO THE STAGE.
>> WE'LL HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
GROUP ON THE STAGE.
>> YES, THE PEOPLE ON THE STAGE
WILL BE THE EMERETI WHO HAVE
CHOSEN TO SIT HERE.
I SAW A FEW ALREADY.
AND THE YALE CORPORATION, THE
HONORANDS AND ALL THE DEANS WILL
BE SITTING THERE.
AND HERE COMES -- >> AND THE
BLUE HOOD AGAIN?
>> WELL, THIS IS THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES.
>> RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>> I THINK.
>> AND THESE ARE STILL --
>> UNLESS -- UNLESS THAT IS NOW
MANAGEMENT.
I'M NOT SURE.
I DIDN'T SEE THE FLAGS COMING
DOWN.
>> NO, I DIDN'T EITHER.
BUT THESE ARE STILL GRADUATES
COMING OUT OF CROSS CAMPUS.
A LOT OF THE GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS ARE STAGING
ON CROSS CAMPUS AS WELL.
IT'S JUST A FESTIVAL.
>> WELL, THEY HAVEN'T STARTED
COMING IN YET.
SO, YOU SEE HOW IT DOES TAKE A
VERY LONG TIME TO GET EVERYBODY
IN HERE.
SO, ACTUALLY, THE REAL EVENT
BEGINS AT 11:00.
WE TRY TO BEGIN IT MAYBE A
LITTLE BEFORE.
BUT RIGHT NOW YOU'RE SEEING THIS
INCREDIBLE PROCESSION OF 5,000
GRADUATES FROM EVERYWHERE.
THERE YOU SEE MUSIC ON THE
LEFT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, THE PINK
HOODS.
>> IT'S AMAZING THAT ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING GRADUATE
DEGREES.
YEAH.
SO, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
PRESIDENT YET OR THE PRESIDENT'S
PARTY.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THEM --
>> WE SAW THEM COME BY VERY
BRIEFLY.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE HOOD THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS WEARING.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
AGAIN LATER.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT?
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY.
>> IT'S A VERY SPECIAL GOWN
THAT'S CREATED FOR THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE WEARS ALL THE TIME.
HE WEARS A VERY SPECIAL COLLAR.
>> COLLAR, THANK YOU.
>> VERY, VERY SPECIAL COLLAR
THAT HAS THE NAMES OF ALL OF THE
SCHOOLS ON IT.
AND IT WAS ACTUALLY ONCE --
HERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY -- STOLEN FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE IN 1979.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> WHEN, BY SOMEBODY LEFT A
VAULT OPEN.
AND IT WAS TAKEN.
AND IT WAS GIVEN AS A GIFT FROM
A DONOR.
AND YOU WILL SEE HIM WEARING IT
WITH HIS SPECIAL GOWN ALL AROUND
HIS NECK.
AND RIGHT NOW YOU'LL SEE FILING
INTO THE CROSS CAMPUS IN FRONT
OF THE STAGE, THOUGH I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN SEE IT, A LOT OF
THE FACULTY FROM THE SCHOOLS WHO
ARE BEGINNING.
I SEE THE DEANS OF THE SCHOOL OF
MANAGEMENT.
AND I SEE THE RESIDENT -- SOME
OF THE GRADUATE SCHOOL DEANS
HAVE COME TO PUT THEIR MACES UP
AND TO TAKE THEIR PLACES.
AND ALL OF THE FACULTY WILL BE
SEATED IN THE VERY, VERY FRONT
OF THE COMMENCEMENT THEATER.
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE STAGE.
AND BEHIND THEM AND TO THE SIDES
OF THEM WILL BE THE
UNDERGRADUATES AND ALL THE
SCHOOLS.
>> AND EVENTUALLY ALL OF THE
FLAGS WILL BE POSITIONED RIGHT
IN FRONT OF THE STAGE, IS THAT
RIGHT?
>> YES, THEY WILL.
THERE WILL BE A BIG CEREMONY.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THE DAY, AND
I THINK YOU'LL ENJOY IT TOO, IS
WHEN THE FLAGS COME DOWN THIS
CENTER AISLE AND YOU'LL HEAR THE
SCHOOLS AND THE COLLEGES WHICH
THESE FLAGS REPRESENT YELLING
AND CHEERING HAPPILY TO SEE
THEIR SCHOOL BEING REPRESENTED.
SO HERE COME PEOPLE -- I CAN'T
QUITE SEE WHAT THAT COLOR IS.
>> I THINK IT'S ORANGE.
: IT MAY BE ARCHITECTURE THAT'S
COMING.
ALL THE SALMON PINK -- I THINK
THAT'S ARCHITECTURE.
I DIDN'T SEE WHO WAS AT THE HEAD
OF THE PROCESSION.
I WASN'T LOOKING.
JUST BEGINNING TO COME IN.
AND SO, FOR THOSE WHO WEREN'T
HERE IN THE BEGINNING, I THINK
IT'S WORTH SAYING AGAIN THAT
WHAT IS NOW HAPPENING OUTSIDE
THE GATES BESIDES THE FACT THAT
THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS ARE
ENTERING IS THAT THE CORPORATION
PARTY, THE PRESIDENT, THE
FACULTY OF ARTS AND SCIENCE AND
THE YALE COLLEGE DEAN'S OFFICE
ARE ALL PROCESSING THROUGH THE
UNDERGRADUATES, THE FELLOWS OF
THE COLLEGES AND THEIR --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND THEY'RE GREETING THEM.
THEY'RE SAYING GOOD MORNING.
THEY'RE EXCHANGING HELLOS.
>> HERE IS A WONDERFUL VIEW --
THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
>> THEY'RE CHEERING EVERYBODY
AND SAYING HELLO.
>> WHAT AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
>> OKAY.
HERE COMES LAW.
>> YEP.
WEARING PURPLE.
YEAH, HERE THEY COME.
THE LAW SCHOOL HEADED BY MIKE
THOMPSON, THE LONG-SERVING
MARSHAL.
GUIDO CALABRESI THERE, WEARING
HIS ITALIAN GOWN.
HEATHER DIRKIN, THE NEW DEAN OF
THE SCHOOL SEE.
AND HERE'S THE GRADUATES.
>> AND HERE COMES DIVINITY ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
>> YES, THEY'RE WEARING THE
SCARLET.
HERE COMES DIVINITY AND DEAN
STERLING.
YES.
>> THAT'S THE GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
ARTS AND SCIENCES.
HELLO, GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS
AND SCIENCES.
YOU LOOK WONDERFUL IN YOUR
BLUE.
YAY!
>> AND WE'RE STARTING TO HEAR
THE MUSIC.
>> YES, THE BAND IS BEGINNING TO
LEAD POPLE THROUGH THE GATES.
SO, AS SOON AS THE PEOPLE START
COMING DOWN THIS AISLE HERE, AND
IT WILL STILL TAKE TIME FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE TO ENTER HERE.
>> HERE COMES THE BAND THROUGH
PHELPS GATE.
AND THERE'S THE MACE.
STILL HELD HIGH.
>> I THINK THEY'RE NOT COMING
DOWN THE AISLE YET, ARE THEY?
>> NO, NOT DOWN THE AISLE.
JUST THROUGH THE GATE.
>> HERE'S THE ROTC.
THIS IS THE FLAGS.
>> CARMEN DELAVALLADE.
>> YES, HERE'S THE CORPORATION.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE,
HAVE A WONDERFUL COMMENCEMENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
DR. PETER SALOVEY: TO THE
STUDENTS OF THE CLASS OF 2019
AND THEIR PARENTS, FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS.
WELCOME TO THE 318th
COMMENCEMENT OF YALE
UNIVERSITY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE GATHER TO RECOGNIZE THE
EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO COMPLETE YOUR PROGRAMS
OF STUDY.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORT, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR TALENT, AND YOUR
INTELLECT.
WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN EXPRESSING
GRATITUDE FOR ALL WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS.
YOUR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
TEACHERS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE YALE COMMUNITY.
IN KEEPING WITH THE TRADITION OF
THIS OCCASION, I NOW CALL ON THE
UNIVERSITY CHAPLAIN TO OFFER AN
INVOCATION.
SHARON KUGLER: WITH DEEP
GRATITUDE TO THE QUINNIPIAC
PEOPLE FOR THIS LAND ON WHICH W
STAND, MY BELOVED YALE FAMILY,
INVITE YOU TO JOIN IN ME IN THE
SPIRIT OF PRAYER.
ALMIGHTY AND LOVING CREATOR YOU
ARE THE FORCE THAT LIGHTS THE
STARS.
THE ARCHITECT OF EVERY CELL, TE
SOURCE OF ALL TRUTH.
WE STAND IN THE DAZZLING BEAUT
OF THIS MORNING AS MANY LIVING
EXPRESSIONS OF ONE MYSTERY, A
MYSTERY BEYOND ALL TELLING.
WE WHO SHARE THIS BEAUTIFUL, B
ACHING WORLD, WE WHO LOOK AT TH
SAME SUN AND THE SAME MOON, ARE
A PEOPLE CALLED TO COMMUNAL
RESTORATION.
AS STUDENTS OF YOUR HANDIWORK
HAVE GATHERED HERE FROM
THROUGHOUT THE EARTH WITH
EXQUISITE AMBITIONS AND HAVE
BLESSED AT THIS PLACE WITH THE
JOB OF SEEKING YOUR LIGHT AND
YOUR TRUTH.
OUR GOD OF ALL GENERATIONS, YO
ARE THE GUARDIAN OF WHERE WE AR
GOING AND WHO WE ARE BECOMING.
AS WE PREPARE TO TAKE LEAVE OF
THIS SPACE, MAY WE EXUDE AN
INTELLIGENCE THAT IS INSPIRED
JUSTICE, GUIDED BY TENDERNESS,
MOVED BY HOLINESS AND ALWAYS
INFORMED BY LOVE.
FROM THIS MOMENT OF AWE AND
BEYOND, FILL OUR HEARTS WITH AN
IMAGINATIVE DARING, ONE THAT
STIRS US TO BECOME A LIVING AND
VIBRANT EXAMPLE OF SHALOM, OF
SALAAM, OF SHANTI, OF PEACE.
TOGETHER WE SAY, AMEN.
DR. MARVIN CHUN: MR. PRESIDENT,
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREES IN YALE COLLEGE.
FOR THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR OF
ARTS, 844 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR
OF SCIENCE, 503 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT, TO CONFER ON IT THEM THESE
DEGREES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DR. PETER SA LOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, I BY
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN, AND
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR
THE DEGREES IN THE SCHOOL OF
ARCHITECTURE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ARCHITECTURE, 70 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGN, FIVE IN
NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
VESTED IN ME I CONFER ON YOU THE
DEGREES OF ARCHITECTURE AND
DESIGN AS INSTRUCTED BY THE DEAN
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
MARTA KUZMA, MR. PRESIDENT, THE
SCHOOL OF FINE ART.
FOR THE SCHOOL OF ART, 58 IN
NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I ASK FOR YOU UPON YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THIS
OFFICIAL DEGREE.
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE POWER VESTED
IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU THIS
DEGREE AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL ITS
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
JAMES BUNDY: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE MORE THAN TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF DRAMA.
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN DRAMA,
FOUR IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN FINE
ARTS, 49 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
FINE ARTS, TWO IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
I NOW ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL
ACT TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DEGREES.
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
VESTED IN ME, I HEREBY -- UPON
YOU THE CERTIFICATE AND DEGREES
IN DRAMA DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN
AND ADMIT YOU IT ALL THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
ROBERT LEWIS BLOCKER: MR.
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
DEGREES IN THE SCHOOL OF MUSIC.
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN
PERFORMANCE, ONE IN NUMBER.
FOR THE ARTIST DIPLOMA, ONE IN
NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
MUSIC, 74 IN NUMBER.
MUSICAL ARTS, 28 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
MUSICAL ARTS, 28 IN NUMBER.
MUSICAL ARTS, SIX IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
MUSICAL ARTS, SIX IN NUMBER.
THE SCHOOL AND APPROVED BY THE
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
CORPORATION, I NOW ASK YOU, BY
THE SCHOOL AND APPROVED BY THE
YOUR OFFICIAL ACT, TO CONFER
CORPORATION, I NOW ASK YOU, BY
UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
YOUR OFFICIAL ACT, TO CONFER
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE CERTIFICATE, DIPLOMA AND
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
DEGREES IN MUSIC AS DESIGNATED
THE CERTIFICATE, DIPLOMA AND
BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
DEGREES IN MUSIC AS DESIGNATED
THEIR RIGHTS AND
BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THEIR RIGHTS AND
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RESPONSIBILITIES.
DR. ANN KURTH: MR. PRESIDENT, I
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU
DR. ANN KURTH: MR. PRESIDENT, I
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES IN
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE SCHOOL OF NURSING.
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES IN
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE SCHOOL OF NURSING.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 112.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 112.
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 112 IN
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN
NUMBER.
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 112 IN
FOR THE POST-GRADUATE
NUMBER.
CERTIFICATE IN NURSING, TWO IN
FOR THE POST-GRADUATE
NUMBER.
CERTIFICATE IN NURSING, TWO IN
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
NUMBER.
NURSING PRACTICE, 16 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
NURSING PRACTICE, 16 IN NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREES IN NURSING AS
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
THE DEGREES IN NURSING AS
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
RESPONSIBILITIES.
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DR. INGRID BURKE: MR. PRESIDENT,
[ APPLAUSE ]
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
DR. INGRID BURKE: MR. PRESIDENT,
CANDIDATES FOR THE SCHOOL IN
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
FORESTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CANDIDATES FOR THE SCHOOL IN
STUDIES.
FORESTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
[ APPLAUSE ]
STUDIES.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
[ APPLAUSE ]
FORESTRY, 11 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
FOREST SCIENCE, FOUR IN NUMBER.
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT, 113 IN
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
NUMBER.
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT, 113 IN
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
NUMBER.
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE, 29 IN
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
NUMBER.
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE, 29 IN
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREES IN FORESTRY AND
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES AS
THE DEGREES IN FORESTRY AND
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES AS
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
RESPONSIBILITIES.
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RESPONSIBILITIES.
DR. EDWARD SNYDER: MR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DR. EDWARD SNYDER: MR.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DEGREES IN THE SCHOOL OF
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
MANAGEMENT.
DEGREES IN THE SCHOOL OF
FOR THE DEGREE OF MAST OF
MANAGEMENT.
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION, 394 IN
FOR THE DEGREE OF MAST OF
NUMBER, FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION, 394 IN
OF ADVANCED MANAGEMENT, 69 IN
NUMBER, FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER
NUMBER.
OF ADVANCED MANAGEMENT, 69 IN
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN
NUMBER.
MANAGEMENT STUDIES, 42 IN
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN
NUMBER.
MANAGEMENT STUDIES, 42 IN
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THIS SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THIS SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREES IN MANAGEMENT AS
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
SUBMITTED BY THE DEAN AND CONFER
THE DEGREES IN MANAGEMENT AS
UPON YOU ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
SUBMITTED BY THE DEAN AND CONFER
RESPONSIBILITIES.
UPON YOU ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS [ APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. GREGORY STERLING: MR.
CONGRATULATIONS [ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DR. GREGORY STERLING: MR.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
IN THE DIVINITY SCHOOL.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARTS
IN THE DIVINITY SCHOOL.
IN RELIGION, 69 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARTS
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
IN RELIGION, 69 IN NUMBER.
DIVINITY, 49 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
DIVINITY, 49 IN NUMBER.
SACRED THEOLOGY, 14 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
SACRED THEOLOGY, 14 IN NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO GRANT THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO GRANT THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREES IN RELIGION,
VESTED IN ME I CONFER UPON YOU
DIVINITY AND THEOLOGY AS
THE DEGREES IN RELIGION,
DESIGNATED BIT DEAN.
DIVINITY AND THEOLOGY AS
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
DESIGNATED BIT DEAN.
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DR. HEATHER GERKEN: MR.
CONGRATULATIONS.
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DR. HEATHER GERKEN: MR.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DEGREES IN THE LAW SCHOOL.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
FOR THE DEGREE OF JURIS DOCTOR,
DEGREES IN THE LAW SCHOOL.
212 IN NUMBER, FOR MASTER OF
FOR THE DEGREE OF JURIS DOCTOR,
LAWS, 28 IN NUMBER, AND FOR THE
212 IN NUMBER, FOR MASTER OF
DEGREE DOCTOR -- TWO IN NUMBER.
LAWS, 28 IN NUMBER, AND FOR THE
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
DEGREE DOCTOR -- TWO IN NUMBER.
BY THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION, I
BY THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
SHALL ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION, I
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
SHALL ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME, I SHALL CONFER
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN THE LAW
VESTED IN ME, I SHALL CONFER
SCHOOL WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
UPON YOU THE DEGREES IN THE LAW
DEAN AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU TO
SCHOOL WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
DEAN AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU TO
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DR. LYNN COOLEY, MR. PRESIDENT,
[ APPLAUSE ]
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
DR. LYNN COOLEY, MR. PRESIDENT,
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
ADVANCED STUDY, TWO IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
SCIENCE, 295 IN NUMBER.
ARTS, 279 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ARTS, 279 IN NUMBER.
PHILOSOPHY, 381 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
PHILOSOPHY, 381 IN NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREES IN THE GRADUATE
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
SCHOOL AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN
THE DEGREES IN THE GRADUATE
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
SCHOOL AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
[ APPLAUSE ]
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. STEN VERMUND, MR. PRESIDENT,
CONGRATULATIONS.
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
DR. STEN VERMUND, MR. PRESIDENT,
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES IN
I HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES IN
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
229 IN NUMBER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
229 IN NUMBER.
THE FACULTY OF THIS SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THIS SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THIS
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREE.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THIS
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREE.
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
THE DEGREE IN PUBLIC HEALTH AS
VESTED IN ME, I CONFER UPON YOU
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
THE DEGREE IN PUBLIC HEALTH AS
YOU IT ALL ITS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
RESPONSIBILITIES -- ITS RIGHTS
YOU IT ALL ITS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
RESPONSIBILITIES -- ITS RIGHTS
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
DR. ROBERT ALPERN: MR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
DR. ROBERT ALPERN: MR.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES
PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR TO
IN THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR DEGREES
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IN THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
MEDICAL SCIENCE, 40 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
MEDICAL SCIENCE, 40 IN NUMBER.
BY THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION, I
BY THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
SHALL ASK, BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT,
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION, I
TO CONFER UPON THEM THIS
SHALL ASK, BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT,
DEGREE.
TO CONFER UPON THEM THIS
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN GLOBAL
DEGREE.
MEDICINE, ONE IN NUMBER, FOR THE
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN GLOBAL
DEGREE OF MASTER OF HEALTH
MEDICINE, ONE IN NUMBER, FOR THE
SCIENCE, 35 IN NUMBER.
DEGREE OF MASTER OF HEALTH
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
SCIENCE, 35 IN NUMBER.
MEDICINE, 87 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
MEDICINE, 87 IN NUMBER.
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREES.
VESTED IN ME I SHALL CONFER THE
DR. SALOVEY: BY THE AUTHORITY
DEGREE IN MEDICAL SCIENCE AND DO
VESTED IN ME I SHALL CONFER THE
CONFER UPON YOU THE CERTIFICATE
DEGREE IN MEDICAL SCIENCE AND DO
IN MEDICAL DEGREES IN GLOBAL
CONFER UPON YOU THE CERTIFICATE
MEDICINE, HEALTH SCIENCE AND
IN MEDICAL DEGREES IN GLOBAL
MEDICINE AS DESIGNATED BY THE
MEDICINE, HEALTH SCIENCE AND
DEAN.
MEDICINE AS DESIGNATED BY THE
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
DEAN.
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DR. LYNN COOLEY: [  SPEAKING IN
CONGRATULATIONS.
LATIN  ].
DR. LYNN COOLEY: [  SPEAKING IN
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
LATIN  ].
DR. SALOVEY: [  RESPONSE IN
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
LATIN  ] [ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
DR. SALOVEY: [  RESPONSE IN
]
LATIN  ] [ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
THANK YOU.
]
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
MAKING ME WORK HARDER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
♪ THY PRAISE ALONE, O LORD, DOTH
REIGN IN SION THINE OWN HILL ♪
♪ THEIR VOWS TO THEE THEY DO
MAINTAIN AND EVEORE FULFILL ♪
♪ FOR THAT THOU DOST THEIR
PRAYERS STILL HEAR AND DOST
THERETO DEGREE ♪
♪ THY PEOPLE ALL BOTH FAR AND
NEAR WITH TRUST SHALL COME TO
THEE ♪
♪
♪ OF THY GREAT JUSTICE HEAR O
GOD OUR HEALTH OF THEE DOTH RISE
♪
♪ THE HOPE OF ALL THE EARTH
ABROAD AND THE SEA-COASTS
LIKEWISE ♪
♪ WE DEDICATE OUR LIVES ANEW
THAT LIGHT AND TRUTH WILL SHINE
♪
♪ THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, O GOD,
WE PRAY ♪
♪ TO ALL OF HUMANKIND ♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: WE'LL NOW PROCEED
TO THE AWARDING OF HONORARY
DEGREES.
THE 11 INDIVIDUALS WE HONOR THIS
MORNING SERVE AS EXAMPLES TO
YOU, OUR GRADUATES, TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO ASPIRE TO EXCELLENCE.
AND TO VALUE THOSE ELEMENTS OF
HUMAN CHARACTER THAT THEY
EMBODY.
CREATIVITY, CURIOSITY,
DISCIPLINE, INTEGRITY, AND A
PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE.
THEIR PRESENCE HERE ALSO HONORS
YOU WHO GRADUATE TODAY AND ALL
OF US WHO ARE HERE TO SALUTE
YOU.
I WILL NOW, AS IS CUSTOMARY,
CALL UPON THE PROVOST TO PRESENT
THE CANDIDATES FOR HONORARY
DEGREES.
DR. POLAK: MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE
THE HONOR TO PRESENT THE
CANDIDATES FOR HONORARY
DEGREES.
FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
SOCIAL SCIENCE, LAWRENCE S.
BACOW, SCHOLAR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: LAWRENCE S. BACOW,
VANGUARD OF VERITAS, YOU
CHAMPION HIGHER EDUCATION.
TO SEEK TRUTH, EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THE GREATER GOOD.
FROM PONTIAC, MICHIGAN, TO THE
BANKS OF THE CHARLES RIVER, YOU
HAVE ACQUIRED A GOOD NAME BY
ACTING WITH WISDOM AND
INTEGRITY.
WE PROUDLY WELCOME YOU TO THE
YALE FAMILY AS WE CONFER ON YOU
THIS DOCTOR OF SOCIAL SCIENCE
DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF DIVINITY, SISTER HELEN
PREJEAN, DEATH PANEL
ABOLITIONIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: SISTER HELEN
PREJEAN, EMISSARY OF HOPE.
YOU GO TO THE MARGINS OF
SOCIETY.
TO THE POOR, FORGOTTEN, AND
ALONE.
TO SHARE GOD'S LOVE.
IN BEARING WITNESS AND RAISING
YOUR VOICE, YOU HAVE CHANGED
HEARTS, TRANSFORMED CATECHISM
AND OPENED OUR EYES TO THE VALUE
OF ALL HUMAN BEINGS NO MATTER
WHO THEY ARE OR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
IN APPRECIATION FOR YOUR MISSION
OF JUSTICE AND MERCY, WE HUMBLY
PRESENT YOU WITH THIS DOCTOR OF
DIVINITY DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF FINE ARTS, CARMEN DE
LAVALLADE, PERFORMING ARTIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: GRANDAME OF DANCE,
YOU ARE A STORYTELLING WORKING
IN THE MEDIUM OF MOVEMENT.
FROM BROADWAY TO HOLLYWOOD, TO
YALE TO THE METROPOLITAN OPERA,
AUDIENCES HAVE FALLEN UNDER YOUR
SPELL.
ENCHANTED BY YOUR GRACE AND
SKILL.
CHOREOGRAPHER AND TEACHER,
ACTRESS AND ARTIST, IN
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR PIONEERING
CREATIVITY ON MANY STAGES, WE
PROUDLY BESTOW ON YOU THIS
DOCTOR OF FINE ARTS DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF HUMANITIES, MARY
BEARD, CLASSICIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: MARY BEARD, SCHOLAR
OF THE PEOPLE.
YOU EXCAVATE THE PAST AND
CHALLENGE OUR VIEW OF THE
PRESENT.
WITH -- HUMOR AND BRILLIANCE,
YOU FIND FRESH INSIGHTS IN
NEGLECTED CORNERS OF ANTIQUITY
AND STIMULATE DEBATE IN MODERN
FORUMS.
FEARLESS THINKER, CURIOUS GUIDE,
FOR INSPIRING US TO LOOK ANEW AT
HISTORY AND OURSELVES, WE ARE
PRIVILEGED TO AWARD YOU THIS
DOCTOR OF HUMANITIES DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF HUMANE LETTERS.
STRIVE MASIYIWA, ENTREPRENEUR
AND PHILANTHROPIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: STRIVE MASIYIWA,
YOU SEE OPPORTUNITIES OTHERS
MISS.
AND DEMONSTRATE THE COURAGE OF
YOUR CONVICTIONS AT EVERY TURN.
BRAVE VISIONARY, BOLD BUSINESS
LEADER, AND DEVOTED HUMANITARIA.
YOUR INNOVATION AND GENEROSITY
HAVE TRANSFORMED A CONTINENT AND
IMPROVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
FOR INSPIRING US TO TACKLE GREAT
CHALLENGES, LEAD WITH HONOR AND
SERVE OTHERS, YALE IS PRIVILEGED
TO CONFER ON YOU THIS DOCTOR OF
HUMANE LETTERS DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF FINE ARTS, SHEILA
HICKS, ARTIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: SHEILA HICKS,
WEAVING GLOBAL TRADITIONS, YOU
FASHION MASTERPIECES OF TEXTURE,
COLOR, STRUCTURE AND SCALE THAT
ARE UNIQUELY YOUR OWN.
IN YOUR HANDS, FIBER AND FOUND
OBJECTS ARE TRANSFORMED,
CONFOUNDING CATEGORIES AND
ELEVATING OUR PUBLIC SPACES.
IN GRATITUDE FOR THE BEAUTY AND
MEANING YOU HAVE KNITTED
TOGETHER IN A LIFETIME OF
SUBLIME WORK, WE ARE DELIGHTED
TO PRESENT YOUR THIRD YALE
DEGREE, DOCTOR OF FINE ARTS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF HUMANE LETTERS, INDRA
NOOYI, BUSINESS LEADER.
DR. SALOVEY: INDRA NOOYI,
INTREPID TRAILBLAZER, YOU HAVE
LED WITH PURPOSE, ASCENDING THE
CORPORATE LADDER AND ENCOURAGING
WOMEN AND GIRLS TO PICTURE
THEMSELVES IN THE C SUITE.
WITH BRILLIANCE AND FORTITUDE
YOU HAVE EMBRACED CHANGE, SEIZED
OPPORTUNITIES AND SET AN
ENDURING EXAMPLE OF SUCCESS.
GLOBAL ROLE MODEL, IN
RECOGNITION OF YOUR ACHIEVEMENTS
IN BUSINESS AND FOR SOCIETY, WE
ARE HONORED TO PRESENT YOU WITH
YOUR SECOND YALE DEGREE, DOCTOR
OF HUMANE LETTERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF HUMANE LETTERS, GLORIA
STEINEM, WOMEN'S RIGHTS
ADVOCATE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: GLORIA STEINEM, YOU
SPEARHEADED A MOVEMENT AND
CHANGED OUR WORLD.
GIVING WOMEN GREATER FREEDOM TO
CHART THEIR OWN COURSES IN
LIFE.
OPENING DOORS FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME, YOU FOUGHT TO EXPAND
RIGHTS AND ADVANCE LIBERTY,
EQUALITY AND HUMANITY.
FEMINIST AND FIRE BRAND, ICON
AND ECONOCLAST, YALE IS PROUD TO
AWARD YOU THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR
OF HUMANE LETTERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF HUMANE LETTERS, JAMES
A. BAKER III, PUBLIC SERVANT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: JAMES BAKER, AS
CABINET SECRETARY, FOREIGN ENVOY
AND TRUSTED ADVISER, YOU HAVE
PLACEED NATIONAL INTERESTS ABOVE
SELF-INTEREST.
YOUR LASER SHARP UNDERSTANDING
OF PEOPLE, POWER AND POLICY
HELPED GUIDE A GENERATION OF
U.S. PRESIDENTS.
SHAPING OUR GOVERNMENT AND OUR
WORLD.
IN RECOGNITION OF YOUR STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO THIS COUNTRY AND
ITS DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS,
YALE IS HONORED TO BESTOW ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF HUMANE
LETTERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK: FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF SOCIAL SCIENCE,
CYNTHIA MOSS, WILDLIFE
RESEARCHER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: CYNTHIA MOSS, YOU
HAVE BROUGHT INTERNATIONAL
ATTENTION TO THE ELEPHANTS OF
AMBESELE.
THROUGH RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY,
YOU SHOW US HOW THESE MAJESTIC
ANIMALS LIVE, LOVE AND DIE AND
THE LESSONS THEY OFFER TO
HUMANKIND.
FOR YOUR EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS
TO CONSERVE WILDLIFE AND ITS
HABITATS, AND FOR HELPING US
FIND BEAUTY, DIGNITY AND JOY
BEYOND OUR SPECIES, WE ARE
HONORED TO BESTOW ON YOU THIS
DOCTOR OF SOCIAL SCIENCE
DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. POLAK AND FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF LETTERS, CHIMAMANDA
ADICHIE, AUTHOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DR. SALOVEY: CHIMAMANDA ADICHIE,
YOUR STORIES OF WAR, MIGRATION,
HOME AND HEARTBREAK BRING THE
GREAT RICHNESS AND MULTIPLICITY
OF HUMAN EXPERIENCE TO LIFE.
WITH COURAGE AND CLARITY YOU
CALL US TO DO BETTER FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS.
FOR OURSELVES AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS AROUND THE GLOBE.
IN APPRECIATION FOR YOUR SUPERB
TALENT AND LEADERSHIP IN
LITERATURE AND THE PUBLIC
SPHERE, WE ARE HONORED TO
PRESENT YOUR SECOND YALE DEGREE,
DOCTOR OF LETTERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
♪ LET LIGHT AND TRUTH SUFFUSE
THE MIND AND SPREAD THROUGHOUT
THE SHADOWED HEART ♪
♪ AS WHAT WE KNOW IS REDEFINED
THROUGH SCIENCE, SCHOLARSHIP AND
ART ♪
♪ OUR FOUNDERS KNEW THAT FAITH
REQUIRES THE DISCIPLINE OF
STURDY THOUGHT ♪
♪ THEY TRUSTED THAT THE SPIRIT'S
FIRES BURN BRIGHTEST WHERE THE
TRUTH IS SOUGHT ♪
♪ WE'VE LEARNED THE WISEST
PRAYER THEY PRAYED WAS THAT MORE
LIGHT WOULD GUIDE THEIR WAYS ♪
♪ FOR WE, LIKE THEM, HAVE BEEN
REMADE BY UNEXPECTED, SLANTED
RAYS ♪
♪ SO LET THE GIFT OF GATHERED
LIGHT PERVADE THE WAYS WE LEARN
AND KNOW ♪
♪ AWAKING WONDER AND DELIGHT ♪
♪ WHILE KNOWLEDGE, TRUTH AND
WISDOM GROW ♪
GREGORY STERLING: I INVITE YOU
TO PRAY WITH ME.
GOD, OUR PLACES OF ORIGIN VARY,
BUT OUR SOURCE IS ONE.
THE EXPRESSIONS OF OUR HUMANIT
ARE DIVERSE, YET YOU, O GOD, ARE
IN ALL.
OUR PERSPECTIVES DIFFER, BUT M
OUR HOPES FOR THE WORLD BE ONE.
BLESS THESE GRADUATES WITH EYES
TO SEE WHAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN;
WITH MINDS TO GRASP WHAT WE HAV
FOUND INCOMPREHENSIBLE;
WITH HEARTS WILLING TO RISK
FAILURE TO CHANGE WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO ALTER.
THANK YOU FOR THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS WHO HAVE BROUGHT THESE
GRADUATES TO THIS DAY
FOR THE FACULTY AND THE HONORES
WHO HAVE CHANGED OUR WORLD.
AND FOR THIS SPECIAL PLACE THAT
WE KNOW AS YALE, THAT BRINGS US
ALL TOGETHER ON THIS DAY.
AMEN.
♪